B,
two,
one.
Here we are again.
Hey Joe.
Hello Jordan.
How are you doing man?
I'm doing great.
You have the schedule that you have and
the amount of energy and enthusiasm you
maintain what the schedule is very
remarkable because you're not stopping.
You're not slowing down.
I mean you've,
you've had your foot on the gas for like
two solid years now.
Make Hay while the sun shines.
I guess that was what it.
Is that how you feel about it?
Well,
you know,
when you have an opportunity that's
completely preposterous.
You're a fool to take it for granted.
I guess.
So
Sierra,
so tammy and I have been to 100 cities
since January,
so everywhere,
you know,
and part of what keeps us going.
Well first of all I have a really good
crew,
you know,
like the ca guys.
They're really good.
Live nation has been really good.
They make sure that the theaters are
smooth and,
and we've had no problems at all.
And then I have lots of people who are
helping me with my scheduling and Tammy
travels with me and then the lectures
themselves.
Well,
I really like doing them partly because
I do a different lecture every night and
so that keeps me sharp and it makes sure
that I'm thinking about new things all
the time and trying to formulate my
thoughts more precisely and there are
also unbelievably positive.
So that's also,
that's also something that makes it a
lot easier to do because you know,
I go to a city and there's 1500 to 2000
people waiting for me there,
which is staggering in and of itself
wherever I go and they're all,
they're listening intently and,
and it's,
it's a sophisticated discussion or at
least as sophisticated as I can make it.
I'm communicating directly with the
audience and all the people are there to
try to get their lives together.
And so the,
the,
the feeling in the,
in the hall is really,
really positive.
And then I usually talk to about 150
people afterwards and you know,
they're all of them,
all of them.
While many of them they just say hi and
they're polite and we have a photograph
and all that.
But lots of them have stories about how
they've been putting their lives
together and they're thrilled to death
about it.
You know,
that they're out of the hole they were
in or they've started a new business or
they've sold a new business or they just
decided to get married or they're going
to have some kids.
Are they fixed up their relationship
with their parents or they quit drinking
or.
And they're not addicted.
I talked to one guy in Europe,
he'd stop.
He was,
he was addicted.
I don't remember what to,
but it wasn't.
It was something that wasn't good.
He,
he'd stopped for nine months and got
nine of his friends to quit too.
So he comes up,
he's just like bouncing,
you know,
he's so damn happy that his life is
better at.
Not only that,
that he had this additional positive
effect on other people.
So,
and it's so fun because I have these
conversations with people.
They're brief,
but they're very personal and they're
very intense,
you know,
because they,
they,
you think people have to trust you to
tell you that their lives weren't going
so well.
And then they have to trust you more to
tell you that they're going better now
because of course what you want when you
tell someone that things are going
better is you want real encouragement
and real sense from the person you're
talking to that they're happy for you.
And I am absolutely thrilled to hear
these things.
A guy was in whole foods this morning.
I went down near where I'm staying and
two of the guys that work behind the
meat counter came out to talk to me and
independently and they'd both been
reading my books and watching my
lectures.
And one of them said he at a seven year
old son,
he really wanted to do right by him.
He was looking for ethical and moral
guidance and he found the books really
helpful and that it was helping him put
his life together.
And,
and so car guy at the car rental place
last night told me the same thing as,
oh,
it's so exciting.
So ridiculously exciting to go
everywhere around the world and to go
into airports are to walk down the
street and have people come up and say,
I've been watching you on youtube.
They often mention you.
I've been listening to what you say.
I've been developing a vision for my
life.
It's really helped me out a lot.
Thanks a lot.
And Jesus like to be able to have that
happen,
you know,
time after time,
day after day,
all over the place.
That's just absolutely.
It makes go into 100 cities,
like continually,
uh,
energizing because it's so positive.
And so.
And then there's all this weird crap in
the press,
you know,
about my dangerous followers and all
this outright nonsense.
And it's so ridiculous.
You know,
I've talked to 250,000
people in it in seven months.
We haven't had one incident that was
negative in that entire time.
Not One.
Nothing,
no misbehavior on anyone's part.
We had one heckler who obviously not a
fan of mine,
given that he was a heckler.
That was it.
Other than that,
the audiences behave perfectly.
They all dress up.
They come in suits,
which is really cool.
A lot of young guys,
they dress up so they have a little suit
competition with me,
which is quite fun.
So that's an additional bonus and yeah,
it's.
It's pretty damn good joe.
I think it's really fantastic and I
think what's going on is it makes me
very optimistic because I think that one
of the things that new media has
provided as these new avenues for
information to get out there and these
new things like these lecture circuits.
When was the last time you saw public
lecture circuits that were popular to
the tune of thousands and thousands of
people.
I saw the ones that you and Sam Harris
did on Youtube and you know Sam's doing
them with a lot of other people as well.
You're doing them with a bottle of Jay
with Dave Rubin as well.
These are the.
I mean this is a very unique thing,
that's for sure.
And also this desire to understand new
paths of behavior and patterns of
thinking and that these are corrective
paths and patterns that can lead you to
a more fulfilled and happier life.
And recognize the pitfalls of certain
types of behavior that people just fall
into and I think oftentimes the between
someone who
lives a fulfilled life and someone who
lives a life filled with disaster is
following incorrect patterns and not
knowing what the correct ones are.
So there's a lot of good people out
there that lives shitty lives and they
don't do it because they're.
They're just dumb or because they're
bad.
They do it because they've been
influenced by certain patterns.
They fallen into patterns,
whether it's because of the people that
they surround themselves with or the
neighborhood that grew up,
the people that are around them and have
this way of being and they kind of fall
into that or it's drugs or alcohol or
whatever it is,
but then they find a new one and then
they can slide right into that new one
and all of a sudden they feel energized
and they wake up in the morning instead
of hung over there getting exercise in
there,
eating healthy.
They're starting to think about things
correctly and do good things in the
momentum of them.
Doing those good things leads them to
feel good about themselves and energized
and this,
these are all things that you promote
and then I think are genuinely really
significant,
really important,
but he gets.
But the thing is a gets maligned.
It gets you get pushed into this weird
one,
but if what we were talking about before
the podcast by a small select group of
people,
it's a very small but vocal minority
that wants to misrepresent you and then
there's the periphery that listen to
this small group and then they sort of
pair it those words out without any real
thinking about what you've said.
Well,
you know,
one of the things that I have made a
mistake about in the past that I just
realized in the last couple of weeks was
that,
you know,
people often accused me and they say,
well,
most of the people that listened to you
are men.
And I think that,
you know,
when you're accused like that,
your automatic responses.
Well,
you wouldn't be accused if you weren't
doing something wrong.
So there must be something wrong about
that.
It's like,
why isn't it 50 percent women?
And so I've said things like,
well,
you know,
80 percent of the people who watch
youtube videos are men.
And so the fact that 80 percent of the
people who watch my videos are men.
Isn't that surprising given that base
rate?
But then about three weeks ago I started
thinking,
well,
what,
what the hell am I doing?
It's like,
what?
Is there some wrong with talking to men?
Is that actually a problem?
So like I'm trying to,
I'm trying,
I mean I didn't set out to do that
specifically,
but if that's the way it's working out
and,
and there is a majority of men coming to
my shows say then is that,
why is that s all of a sudden supposed
to be a bad thing?
I'm asking men to,
you know,
to be more honest and especially in
their speech and their thinking and to
be more responsible for themselves and
for their family and for their community
and to grow up and to shoulder their
burden and to live a responsible and
meaningful life.
And putting those two things together
conceptually.
And it's like.
And then there's an accusation about
that is if there's something wrong.
And I thought,
well,
why am I even playing into this?
It's like,
fine,
I'm talking to men,
I'm encouraging them and I am absolutely
thrilled every time someone comes up to
me,
um,
and that's happening.
I may be a 100 times a week or something
like that and tells me one
of these stories about how they put
their life together.
It's like I'm absolutely thrilled about
that.
And so I don't see,
it's just a sign of how pathological our
times have become in some sense that
there would have been any guilt about
that to begin with because how is that
not a good thing,
man?
It's weird.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
a lot of that has to do with this
concept that men are running everything
and that men have this massive
advantage.
There's a white male advantage and
privilege that we all enjoy and share
and that men have this advantage
financially.
There's disparity in terms of the gender
gap in pay and income and that if you
were really a good person,
you would be looking out.
He would be trying to balance that out
and then you wouldn't be trying to pump
up the winning team.
Well,
that's it,
and that's part of that narrative that,
well,
if there's winners there,
there has to be losers,
and the reason that there are losers is
because there's winners and that's
complete bloody nonsense because as far
as I'm concerned that,
and I really believe this,
is that every single person who sets out
to put themselves together ethically is
a net positive to everyone around them.
There's no downside to that.
You know,
my book has been criticized by people
who've read it very poorly,
especially chapter one,
when I talk about hierarchies that I'm
somehow supporting the idea that power
in a hierarchy is the right way to be
and there's absolutely nothing in what
I've written that suggest that at all.
I'm suggesting that human hierarchies
are very complex and that the way that
you win in a human hierarchy is by being
competent and reciprocal and so and so.
I mean,
for example,
even if you're selfish,
let's say you got to think very
carefully about what that would mean.
If you were selfish and awake because
you have to work to take care of
yourself and what you want say in this
moment,
but then there's you tomorrow and
there's you next week and there's you
next month,
next year and 10 years from now and when
you're old.
So because you're self conscious and
because you're aware of the future,
you're actually a community unto
yourself and if you're selfish and
impulsive,
all that means is that you're serving
the person you are right now.
You know in that impulsive way but not
the person you are going to be.
And so that's not a good grounds for any
sort of ethical behavior.
And I see that if you serve yourself
properly,
there's no difference between serving
your family properly in serving your
community properly.
That those things all mesh in a kind of
a harmonious manner.
And one of the things that's really been
effective in the lecture tour is a
discussion about that idea and its
relationship between the relationship
between that and meaning and
responsibility.
Because one of the things that strikes
the audience's silent constantly because
I'm always listening to them to see,
you know,
when,
when the attention is maximally focused
is whenever I pointed out to people that
the antidote to the meaninglessness of
their life and the suffering and the
malevolence that they might be
displaying because they're resentful and
bitter about how things have turned out.
The antidote to that is to take on more
responsibility for themselves and for
other people and that that's
aspirational,
which is Kinda cool.
You know,
the conservative types,
the duty types and I'm not complaining
about them,
you know,
they're basically saying,
well,
this is how you should act because in
some sense that's your duty,
right?
That's how a good citizen would act.
And that's a reasonable argument.
But the case that I've been making is
more of that.
Well,
there is a,
there is value distinctions between
things.
Some things are worth doing and some
things aren't.
And you can kind of discover what that
is for yourself and then you should aim
at the things that are most worth doing.
And what you'll find if you watch
carefully,
is that the things that you find worth
doing are almost always associated with
an increase in responsibility.
Because if you think about the people
you admire,
for example,
you spontaneously admire people and
that's a manifestation of the instinct.
Imitate getting people are very
imitative.
You don't admire people who don't take
care of themselves,
like unless there's something wrong with
you,
you at least want an admirable person to
be accountable for themselves.
And then if they've got something
leftover so they can be accountable for
their family,
well then that's a net.
Plus obviously that's someone you think
is solid and then maybe they take care
of some more people.
They have a business or they're involved
in the community in some positive way.
You see,
well that's a person who's pattern of
being is worth imitating.
And so and that's all associated with
responsibility and it's so interesting
because it's as if it's as if everybody
kind of knows this,
but that it hasn't crystallized.
It's like,
well,
you should be responsible because that's
what a good citizen is.
It's known,
oh,
you should be responsible because you
need to have a deep meaning in your life
to offset the suffering so you don't get
bitter and the way you do that is to
bear a heavy load,
you know,
to get yourself in check for you now and
for you in the future and then to do the
same for your family and your community
and that there's real nobility in that
and there's real meaning and more.
The other thing that I've been
suggesting to people,
and I also believe this is that,
and I think that the guys that have come
to talk to me,
especially the ones that have had real,
real rough lives,
they really understand this.
If you don't get your act together and
you let yourself slide,
then what kind of moves in to take the
place of what you could have been.
It's something that's really not good at
all.
So it's not only that if you're living a
like a dissolute life,
that you're not aiming at anything
positive and so you don't have any real
meaning and your subsumed by anxiety and
all of that hopelessness.
But something kind of hellish moves in
there to,
to,
to occupy that place and so then you end
up making things worse.
And when you know,
one of the things I learned about
studying totalitarian systems,
whether they were on the right or the
left,
was that part of the reason that the
totalitarian horrors of the 20th century
manifested themselves was because
average people didn't take on the proper
responsibility.
They shut their eyes when they're,
I should have been open even though they
knew it and they did and said things
they knew they shouldn't have done and
said.
And that was what supported those
horrible systems.
So if you don't get your act together,
then you leave a little space for hell.
And I really believe that.
Don't you think when things are
happening like something like Nazi
Germany,
I would imagine that during that time,
the people that were not in supportive,
it felt helpless.
Whether you're in Germany,
you're a part of this country,
this country is turning towards this
horrible situation where Jewish people
are being put on trains.
And you know,
the people that didn't speak out in
that,
I don't necessarily know if it's a lack
of discipline or just complete fear and
paralysis and fear for sure.
I mean,
you know,
knowledge of how to deal with it or to
wanting to protect your family as well.
So wanting to step out of line.
Absolutely.
Oh well that's the thing.
The problem is that if you're going to
forestall that sort of thing,
you have to do it early enough because
the longer you wait,
the higher the price you pay for it.
But it's hard to take that jump early
because you're not exactly sure where
it's going.
That's true.
And you're not well and you're also
likely to be jumped on.
I mean you can see that happening in our
own culture.
You know,
you make a mistake on twitter or even
something that isn't a mistake and you
know,
you can pay a well what feels to be a
pretty high price or whether it is a
high price or not.
It's hard to tell because twitter is so
weirdly fictional,
you know,
it's so hard to to get your to get a
grasp on exactly what's going on.
Let's say it's also your comprehension
of what.
What is the emotional reaction to people
that you don't know being mean to you?
Like this is like,
what is that price and people.
Some people want to dismiss that as
being not just nothing.
It's not that big a deal,
but it is a big deal.
It causes people to commit suicide.
I mean it has.
Absolutely.
Bullying online has caused many people
to commit suicide.
Well,
the thing is,
you know,
when you.
The weird thing about that online
communication is that like I find that I
tend to react to a negative twitter
comment as if it's someone sitting
across from me talking to me that I know
now it's not and I don't even know if
the person is real or because their
accounts are often anonymous.
Right?
So that person isn't really real,
but your emotional responses still.
Well,
someone's gone out of their way to be
harshly critical to you.
You know,
and that doesn't happen that often in
your day to day life and so you know,
if you're a reasonable person,
you're very sensitive to criticism
because it's rare and because you might
be wrong,
especially if there's a lot of people
criticizing you because he kind of has
to be psychopathic in order to just to
brush that off.
You know,
it's like 100 people think I'm wrong.
There's nothing to that.
It's like,
well if it's 100 people out of 100
million but you can't tell on twitter,
then it's irrelevant.
But if it's a mob of 100 people that
show up outside your house,
which is quite kind of what twitter
feels like,
then you think,
well God,
you know,
I must have done something wrong
otherwise,
why would all these people be here?
You know?
And I think that's why so many people
are driven to apologize.
You know,
when they,
when they do something on twitter or do
something and then the twitter mobs go
after them,
they think,
Oh God,
I must've done something wrong.
I should,
you know,
do some soul searching.
And so some of that's not even fear,
it's more like,
it's in a sense,
it's a morality that's misplaced because
of our inability to calibrate the social
messaging.
I mean,
I've stopped almost completely stopped
reading twitter comments in the last
month and I'm definitely better for it
to happier.
Oh yeah.
It's just,
it's too much.
It's too much.
It's too crazy.
Yeah.
Is your number up to now the number of
followers,
but a million on twitter.
That's when it's about time to get out
of dodge.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I'm still following people in
reading what people are posting,
but no,
the comments,
I'm just,
I'm just not worth it.
No,
it's not.
And,
and I think it does have something to do
with the technology itself.
Like I do believe that that small limit
facilitates angry,
impulsive,
responding,
perhaps souls,
you trying to get people to respond to
you.
But the alternative is facebook where
you have these long posts that are just
rambling first drafts that people put
out.
Like when it was,
when I started ranting about politics or
what have you,
I just can't get involved.
They're just too big and then people
jump in and comment on them,
and often their comments are massive as
well.
It's just too verbose.
Whereas the good thing about twitter is
it makes you boil down what you're
trying to say to a very succinct thing.
Although I do enjoy when someone has a
good twitter thread,
like there was a really good twitter
thread.
What was that gentleman's name?
Respectable lawyer to belong.
Respectable law.
He wrote a long history of the sentinel.
These people that are uncontacted tribe
in the Indian see where they,
uh,
the gentleman went there to try to
commission your Christianity and shot
him four arrows.
Yeah.
And he wrote this long history of these
people and what kind of,
what they've had to endure with being,
you know,
a few people going to them and doing
some awful things and diseases and stuff
like that.
So I,
I enjoy when someone will do that,
like these long,
like every now and then someone will use
it in a novel way.
I really liked that.
But there's um,
you know,
a lot of it is just people just trying
to get a reaction and what's the
reaction they can get by pissing you
off.
That's like the best one.
Well,
they also might be the ones that are
most like,
we don't know exactly know what
motivates people to respond on twitter.
And it might be that the fundamental
motivation for twitter response is anger
rather than the desire to share
something because we don't know anything
about how these new communication
techniques function psychologically.
Like maybe twitter is skewed 90 percent
towards people who are impulsively angry
at that moment.
It could easily be,
we don't know,
like,
you know,
if you're driving
in your car and someone cuts you off,
you curse,
you know,
or at least I do.
And it's often a situational issue
rather than a personality flaw on the
part of the other driver.
Even though it's easy to assume that,
but you respond impulsively.
I mean God only knows how much of our
social media networks are setup to
differentially reward impulsive
behavior.
And it's also not that easy to hold
people accountable in some sense.
And maybe there's some utility to that,
but with anonymous accounts and all of
that,
the anonymisity immunity is also
problematic because it certainly enables
people to allow their worst to manifest
themselves,
especially if they're resentful and
angry.
So the only benefit that I can see to
anonymity is it gives you the
opportunity to explore controversial
ideas without true,
true,
I think used correctly.
Well,
that's it.
I think that that's true.
I think there's some utility.
I mean I don't think that it should be
forbidden,
but well,
like most things it's,
it has its advantages and its
disadvantages.
Like most things,
it's not entirely negative to be
anonymous.
Okay.
So I figured something out that I
thought I'd tell you about just took me
like 30 years to figure out and I
figured it out on this tour.
So there's this old idea,
you know,
that you have to rescue your father from
the belly of the whale,
right?
From some monster that's deep in the
abyss.
You see that in Pinocchio for example.
But it's a very common idea.
And I figured out why that is.
I think so.
Imagine that we already know from a
clinical perspective that you know if
you set out a path towards a goal which
you want to do because you need a goal
and you need a path because that
provides you with positive emotion,
right?
So you set up something as valuable,
so that implies a hierarchy is set up,
something as valuable.
You decide that you're going to do that
instead of other things,
so that's kind of a sacrifice because
you're sacrificing everything else to
pursue that and then you experienced a
fair bit of positive emotion and meaning
as you watch yourself move towards the
goal.
And so the implication of that is the
better the goal,
the the more full enrich your experience
is going to be when you pursue it.
So that's one of the reasons have.
That's one of the reasons for developing
a vision and for fleshing yourself out
philosophically because you want to aim
at the highest goal that you can manage.
Okay?
So you do that,
and then what you'll find is that as you
move towards the goal,
there are certain things that,
that,
that you have to accomplish that
frighten you.
You know,
maybe you have to learn to be a better
speaker,
a better writer,
a better thinker.
You have to be better to people around
you,
where you have to learn some new skills
and you're afraid of that,
whatever,
because it's going to stretch you if
you,
if you pursue a goal and it's so,
that'll put you up against challenges.
Okay?
So all the clinical data indicates,
well,
the opposite of safe spaces as Jonathan
Heit has been pointing out that what you
want to do when you identify something
that someone is avoiding,
that they need to do because they're
afraid.
You have them voluntary,
voluntarily confronted,
and so you break it down.
What you try to do,
if you're a behavior therapist,
as you break down the thing,
they're avoiding to smaller and smaller
pieces until you find a piece that's
small enough.
So they'll do it and it doesn't really
matter.
As long as they start it,
they can put the next piece on in the
next piece,
and what happens is they don't get less
afraid.
Exactly.
They get braver,
they get.
It's like there's more of you can and
here's why.
So imagine you do something new and
that's informative,
right?
There's information in the action and
then you can incorporate that
information and turn it into a skill and
turn it into a transformation of your
perceptions so there's more to you
because you've tried something new.
So that's one thing,
but the second thing is there's good
biological evidence for this now that if
you put yourself in a new situation,
then new genes code for new proteins and
build new neural structures and new
nervous system structures.
Same thing happens to some degree when
you work out,
right?
Because your muscles are responding to
the lote,
but your nervous system does that too.
So you imagine that there's a lot of
potential.
You locked in your genetic code and then
if you put yourself in a new situation,
then then the stress,
that's the situational stress that's
produced by that particular situation
unlocks those genes.
And then builds new parts of you,
and so that's very cool because who
knows how much there is locked inside of
you.
Okay,
so now here's the idea.
So let's assume that that scales,
as you take on heavier and heavier
loads,
that more and more of you,
you get more and more informed because
you're doing more and more difficult
things,
but more and more of you gets unlocked.
And so then what that would imply is
that if you got to the point where you
could look at the darkest thing,
so that would be the abyss,
right?
That would be the deepest abyss.
If you could look at the harshest things
like the most brutal parts of the
suffering of the world and the
malevolence of people in society.
If you could look that,
look at that straight and directly,
that that would turn you on maximally.
And so that's the idea of rescuing your
father.
Because imagine that you're like the
potential composite of all your,
all of the ancestral wisdom that's
locked inside of you biologically.
But that's not going to come out at all
unless you stress yourself,
unless you,
unless you challenge yourself and the
bigger the challenge you take on,
the more that's going to turn on and so
that as you take on a broader and
broader range of challenges and you push
yourself harder than more and more of
what you could be turns on and that's
equivalent to transforming yourself into
the ancestral father into all because
you're,
you're like the,
what would you call it,
your,
the consequences of all these living
beings that have come before you and
that's all part of your biological
potentiality.
And then if you can push yourself,
then all of that clicks on and that
turns you into who you could be.
That's an,
that's the re representation of that
positive ancestral father.
So that's why you rescue your father
from the belly of the beast.
So you think that this ultimate goal of
sack of sacrifice and of,
of risking your life in order to save
someone who's truly important to you,
that this somehow or another maximizes
your potential as a human being?
Well,
I think,
I think you can think about it
religiously to so think about it this
way.
So in,
in the Christian story,
for example,
you have Christ does two things that are
met.
Messianic one is takes the suffering of
the world onto himself.
He's not weird idea.
Okay,
so what does that mean?
Let's think about it psychologically.
Well maybe it means that,
well that's your job is the world's full
of suffering and you should accept that
as your responsibility past,
present,
and future.
You're supposed to do something about
that as much as you can about it and
maybe you start with your own localized
suffering,
you know,
put yourself together,
but then you expand that outward and you
decide that it's,
you're not a victim of that even though
you know your part and parcel of it,
but you're,
you're the potential solution to that.
And so you accept that as a
responsibility.
So that's part of taking on load.
That's part of burying across.
You could look at it that way.
The cross is sort of a symbol of the
place of maximal suffering.
Okay?
So you accept that as a challenge.
Not as a,
not as something that you're victimized
by.
Maybe you accept that as the price of
being.
Okay,
so that's one.
That's one responsibility you're
responsible for addressing the suffering
in the world,
so that could give you some meaning
seemed to me.
Then the next thing is there's a story.
Of course,
the Christ met the devil in the desert
and so that's the encounter with
malevolence,
so that would be the other thing because
the two major problems that people face
obviously are suffering,
tragedy and malevolence,
and so that's the other thing that
you're responsible for is that you're
supposed to look at the capacity for
human evil as clearly as you possibly
can.
It's a very terrifying thing.
You know,
that causes posttraumatic stress
disorder and people that aren't
accustomed to it and in the mythologies
that's associated with the encounter
with evil,
it's almost always the case that the
entity that does the encountering,
even if it does it voluntarily,
is is,
is hurt by it.
So the Egyptian God Horus,
for example,
who's the I and the Falcon,
the thing that can see and pay attention
when he encounters is evil.
Uncle Seth,
who's the precursor of Satan,
he loses an eye because it's no joke to
encounter malevolence you know it.
It can really shake you,
but the idea would be that if you can
face the malevolence and you can face
the suffering,
then that maximally that opens the door
to your maximum potential and then the
option.
The optimistic part of that is this is,
this is why it's so useful to peer into
the darkness.
Let's say the optimistic part of that is
is that although the suffering is great
and the malevolence is his deep,
your capacity to transcendent is
stronger,
so what you get out of the most negative
viewpoint is the most positive possible
consequence because one of the things
you'd like to know if you want it to
know something deep about yourself is
that you could face the worst.
That there wasn't prevail,
and I believe that's.
I believe that's correct.
I believe that,
that people are capable of that.
I think that despite how tragic life is
and how malevolent things are,
that fundamentally our spirit,
let's say,
has the capacity to to confront that and
to fix it like psychologically,
to to confronted courageously,
to be able to bear up under that if you
do it voluntarily,
but also to address it not only to deal
with it psychologically,
but to deal with it practically,
and that we could make things much
better.
There's always
striving towards utopia,
right?
Like this is the ultimate goal that if
you ask people,
what would you like out of civilization?
Well,
I'd like everyone to be happy and
everyone to get along and there'd be no
war.
Nothing,
no suffering,
no anything,
but in order to really truly learn about
yourself and about life,
you have to overcome adversity.
You have to experience things,
and I firmly believe that in order to
truly appreciate love,
you have to understand.
I really have felt hate and to really
appreciate comradery.
You have to feel loneliness.
So this is just a part of being a person
for whatever reason.
Yeah.
Well,
maybe you see,
the other thing that I've been thinking
along the same lines is that,
you know,
it isn't so in the,
in the biblical stories,
in Abrahamic Stories,
for example,
Abraham basically hangs around his dad's
tent.
He's like 80.
He's one of these guys that fails to
launch,
you know,
in a big way.
And God eventually gets sick and tired
of him like,
you know,
playing video games in his basement and
says get the hell out there into the
world and have life.
And so he does.
He leaves this,
his father's tent in his community and
his and his country,
which is what he's commanded to do.
And then he goes out and has an
adventure,
but you know,
the first thing he encounters is a
famine and then he encounters a tyranny
and then he encounters a bunch of people
in the state that want to take his wife.
And so you can imagine the Abraham's
response to that is like,
it was a hell of a lot better sitting in
my dad's tent playing video games.
But what's cool about that story,
what I realized when I was doing the
lectures on it last year,
was that that was a call to adventure,
you know,
and,
and that the right way of
conceptualizing what we're talking about
isn't that utopia would be a place where
everyone was happy because,
because,
and I think because of what you just
laid out is you need that polarity,
you know,
and people need a load and we need
adversity and we need difficulty.
We need all of that.
Um,
so maybe what you want is an adventure,
the greatest adventure that you could
have and that would involve,
you know,
something to push against it would
involve real challenge.
And so just to seek that Dostoevsky knew
this because when he wrote notes from
underground,
which I would highly recommend to
everyone who's listening,
it's a great book and it's a very short
book.
He,
he criticized socialist utopia back in
18,
60 weight way before it became this sort
of widespread idea that,
that it is now.
And what does the FCC said was that,
well,
human beings are these very peculiar
creatures.
And if you gave us a utopia so that we
had nothing to do but eat cake and busy
ourself with the continuation of the
species,
that was,
that was his line,
um,
that the first thing we do is smash it
all to bits,
just so that something unexpected and,
and troublesome would happen because
we're built for adventure and not for
peace and happiness.
Lower designed to overcome the natural
world.
The natural world is filled with that
natural world is filled with things
trying to eat.
And this is just everywhere you look.
That's all you observed.
You observed predators and prey and
animals eating vegetables.
And that's it.
And I think that this,
this concept of overcoming adversity so
it's so human.
It's so a part of what we are that I
want to bring it back to you because one
of the things that I've been considering
is that I've said this many times and I
just had a conversation with my good
friend Steve Rinella the other day where
he brought it up independently.
He said,
I think Jordan Peterson is the most
misunderstood and misinterpreted guy in
the world.
He's like,
people are always like,
not just Mrs,
but,
but misstating what you believe in
misstating what you say,
this opposition to you.
This,
uh,
I mean,
like we were talking about this gq
interview,
which I thought was a,
I thought that one was a far more
intelligent than the.
And her approach was far better and far
more reasoned and well thought out than
some of the other attacks on you before.
So the bringing in the varsity level
players is what I'm saying.
It's like,
but I think this is important.
I think this is part of what with what
forges this message is that you are and
you,
and this.
One of the things that,
uh,
Eric Weinstein and I had said about you,
is that you're essentially the hoists
Gracie of the intellectual dark web have
you don't know what that means is the
early days of the UFC,
no one knew what the best martial art
was.
And the idea was like it was all these
martial arts that are running around
independently and that they were all
claiming that they had the best
technique.
And let's see what happens.
And hoists.
Gracie was the one who represented
Jujitsu and went out there and beat all
these people with superior technique and
superior strategy.
South American?
Yes.
He's from Brazil.
I know about him.
Yeah.
And he launched this Brazilian Ju and
his family launched his Brazilian
Jujitsu Empire that has since taken over
the world of martial arts.
But you are the one who's consistently
engaging in these people.
You're the one who's involved.
These valley tuto events where you're
debating these people who are coming at
you hostile with notes and I think is as
uncomfortable as those moments are like
who was the woman that said so what
you're trying to say?
Kathy Newman.
Yeah.
Her.
I think her approach,
I think she misunder estimated you.
I think she underestimated you.
I think she misinterpreted who you are
and she thought that she could come at
you with this Straw man sorta article
and Oh,
argument.
Rather than frame your positions in a
very unflattering way,
it just didn't work.
It was.
It was like the early days of hoists.
Gracie guys would come out,
I'm flailing and get them in an arm bar
and they tap out and they'd go,
fuck,
that's Kinda what happened with you.
But now this woman who you had this
conversation with in Gq,
she was much more skilled.
She was better verbally.
She's shooting her arguments have been
more sense to seem more reasonable,
more well read.
She was able to think on her feet
quicker,
but still these are really important
conversations.
Well it
was a funny day because I went to the,
to the hotel room in Baltimore,
you know,
and I went out of my way to do it and
she was hostile to me the second I
walked into the room.
Really?
Yes.
And that really kind of put me off.
What is your,
how,
how so?
Well,
she basically told me that we were going
to have the war,
you know,
not so many words that,
but just there was a coldness to her and
a distaste for me that was sort of
radiating from her.
So she had to.
She was animous possessed from a union
perspective.
That's the right way of thinking about
it.
One of the ways of thinking about that
is that she had a chip on her shoulder
and relationship to me,
so she'd already formulated who I was in
her imagination and she was also maybe a
form of projection,
so like I was the embodiment of all the
things that she found distasteful and
that's who she was.
So there was no,
there was no willingness to consider on
her part that I could be different than
her preconceptions of.
Right.
And so she was,
she was hostile to me in the way that
you would be if you were prejudiced
against someone right from the
beginning.
And so by the time it was uncomfortable
in the room and by the time and there
was a photo shoot.
And so by the time the conversation
started,
I was more impatient than I would
normally be because one of the things
that I do expect from journalists and
Kathy Newman was like this,
by the way.
And so have some of the other people
that go on and have gone after me.
At least they had the professionalism to
be civil before the interview started.
You know,
like because there's a certain amount of
politeness,
I would say that not that I'm owed,
but that someone you're interviewing is
owed.
If they come out of their way to go talk
to you.
It's just human decency.
There's no real conflict.
Right.
Until you have this conflict,
it's just.
Hello,
nice to meet you guys.
Thank you for coming to human beings
interacting with each other.
Yes.
On,
on,
on.
Relatively professional.
Well,
even just professional,
just professional grounds.
It's like,
well we're both here to do a job and
I've agreed to come but,
but no,
the,
there was palpable enmity in the air.
Right to begin with.
And you know what I actually thought at
the end of that interview,
I thought Jews,
you know,
maybe I'm,
maybe I've done enough interviews
because I found that I was more
impatient than I would've liked to have
been.
Now,
luckily it doesn't seem to have gone
overboard because I'd watching the
comments on that Gq interview and I
think it's got about four and a half
million views,
some ridiculous number of views and
people have said that I was more
impatient and a little harsher than
usual,
which I think is true.
And I thought,
God,
you know,
maybe I'm starting to run out of
patience,
which isn't good.
Right?
And I don't want to run out of patience
because then it,
it will flavor the message that you're
putting out.
Definitely.
And people will take it in the wrong way
and they'll take it in with that
bitterness.
Exactly.
When.
One of the things that I think is very
important is that you don't become
resentful and well and,
and you know,
when I'm on this tour for example,
like there's no resentment for me
because you think,
well this is.
You might think,
well this is a lot of work and I've been
running around like mad and,
and you know,
it takes a lot of organization and it's
quite demanding and all of that.
And that's all true and that none of
that is a complaint.
And I decided with Tammy right at the
beginning that,
well,
first of all that this was going to be
work,
not a vacation because we're not stupid.
We know you can't have everything at the
same time.
If you have any sense,
you're lucky if you get some things that
are good at once,
you know.
So we're very grateful to have that
opportunity and that I was going to
continue to do this as long as I was
thrilled to be in front of the audience.
And then when I meet people afterwards
that I'm not looking at the end of the
line to see when the night ends,
you know,
because I want to be sure that every
single person that comes to meet me,
I'm,
you know,
president president for absolutely
because I am,
I am actually quite taken aback and
thrilled,
I guess is the right word.
Grateful grads.
Better apps that they're there.
It's like God,
man,
some of these people,
you know,
like I was in there coming from all over
the place,
you know,
people fly in from Australia into
Europe,
they've flown,
it's lots of eastern Europeans came to
England.
In fact,
they're making huge tracks or it's guys
who came from like eight.
They took,
took him like 12 hours to get through
Russia to come to Finland to watch the
talk there,
you know,
and,
and then not just a few people like
that.
People are really going way the hell out
of their way,
you know,
and then,
and then they line up and it's not that
it's not inexpensive because these
venues are expensive and,
and all of that.
And I'm,
well I'm,
I'm due and it's the same with the damn
interviews.
It's like I'm doing my best to not take
any of this for granted and not get
annoyed about it.
And,
and that goes for the conflict to.
It's like,
well,
you know,
I've tried to have my agent screen out.
Maybe the more egregious um,
interviews,
you know,
the ones that would just be nothing but
combat because there I find them quite
stressful though I wouldn't say I'm
hiding from them,
but you don't know to begin with how an
interview is going to go and I could
just say,
well I'm done having interviews for
awhile but I,
I can't
help but see that the conflict is a
necessary part of this even though I
don't find it pleasant.
Like people think they accused me of
being a provocateur,
of enjoying the conflict.
And it's actually not true at all.
I don't enjoy it at all.
It usually takes me about three days to
recover from a particularly contentious
interview,
you know,
because I find it,
I find conflict,
interpersonal conflict.
Quite stressful,
you know?
But I think everyone does.
Yes.
And to pretend you don't,
you're either a sociopath or you're a
liar.
Yes,
yes.
Well there are people who seem to enjoy
that kind of intellectual combat.
You know,
that the political types are more like
that.
But,
but I think they still afterwards feel
it and if they read the comments and
people are against them,
it's just that unease it carries.
Well,
you would think so.
I mean I don't even know how people deal
with it because I mean I'm been
fortunate because although,
you know,
I've had a fair bit of negative press
coverage,
the comments in on Youtube in
particular,
which is where the bulk of them are and,
and I would say among the general public
have been overwhelmingly positive.
I don't know what the hell it would be
like to be in a world where that was
reversed,
where,
you know,
the majority of people are against you.
I've seen this,
I've seen it happen with guests that
I've had on the show where I've met them
afterwards and you see a physical effect
on them.
You see them beaten down like Jesus
Christ.
Those comments are so me.
And I'm like,
you can't read those.
You can't read those.
And you see how it's affecting them.
Like they can't sleep.
They real.
Yeah.
It fucks with them.
They'll stay up for nights.
You know,
it's not good.
It's,
it's you're,
you're,
you're taking in all of these opinions
of hundreds if not thousands of people
that you don't even know if they're
coming from a healthy place and and most
of those opinions,
they would not express it that way.
If they were talking,
they could get the same message across.
I think you were ignorant to these
facts.
I think your bias and your perceptions,
even if they had an opinion that was
unflattering,
the way they express it to you,
they'd be considerate about you and your
feelings as a human being and if they
weren't,
you wouldn't take into consideration
what they're saying because this guy's
just an asshole,
but when you just see it in type,
we just see print.
It just doesn't.
It just,
it,
it.
It could be a smart person,
it could be a psycho,
it could be a fool.
It could be anything,
but it's also funny too because the,
the negative comments that are part of
social media seemed to be just as potent
as negative comments in real life,
but the positive comments don't seem to
be as positive as the positive comments
in real life.
Like,
and I don't,
they,
they don't seem as real and I guess
that's partly because we're wired to be
more sensitive to threat and to negative
emotion because,
well,
because we're,
we can be hurt.
Well,
it's also healthy to,
to not stroke your ego too much if
you're just like concentrating only on
like if there's something distasteful if
you go to someone's page and they just
retweet all the positive things that
people say to them because then it has
this sort of reinforcing cycle where
people know that if I say something
really positive with Jordan,
he's going to retweet me.
Like there are some people they engage
in this sort of commerce,
you know,
like you say something positive,
they retweet you and you know,
it's,
it's a little,
it's a little too strokey.
People get really into that stroke in
there.
Yeah.
Well I guess,
yeah.
I guess the danger of that is that
possibility of,
of that ego inflation that you really
want to avoid because that's a bad idea,
bad idea.
You've done a wonderful job of avoiding
those waters because this is a new this
for a guy who's in his fifties who
becomes famous out of nowhere and
doesn't just become fame,
just just become famous,
but becomes this culturally significant
sort of lightening Rod.
I mean,
that's how I view you and a lot of these
talks that you're dealing.
A lot of these,
these debates like you're having with
this woman at Gq or some of your,
your interviews.
What you're doing is you're expressing
yourself in a brave but very
controversial way and a lot of people
are paying attention to this,
but then you're backing it up with your
research or backing it up with real
science.
You're backing up with a tremendous
amount of history of,
of,
of the human race and religion and,
uh,
the scientific studies that have been
done that show correlations between
different types of behaviors and human
beings.
And all this is rich.
It's,
it's very.
It's very rewarding if you could take it
all in.
But when it goes against what people
have the preconceived notions or their
own set of beliefs that they're bringing
to your conversations,
into your debates,
then it creates this hostile,
a battle where what you're saying is,
is,
is very contrary to the way they've been
living their life or the
really saw that in Scandinavia,
Scandinavia.
Well,
I was there.
I went to Stockholm twice in Oslo,
twice in Helsinki twice in Copenhagen,
once in the last month and I spent quite
a bit of a lot of interviews and a lot
of discussion about the so called gender
paradox.
Now it's a very interesting thing
because it's really put their tails into
not in Scandinavia and that makes sense
because the scandinavians are going to
have to deal with this first because
they've gone the farthest down the road
for like making their society gender
equal.
But explain that to me.
I will,
I will.
Okay.
So,
so imagine first of all that there's two
kinds of equality that you might pursue.
One would be equality of opportunity and
so that would mean that there's wide
range of talent across people regardless
of their type,
whatever that might be.
Sex,
gender,
race,
ethnicity.
There's,
there's talent distributed everywhere
and it's kind of a truism and I would
say a truism of the West in the deepest
sense that each of the individuals
within those groups should be put in a
position where they,
their talents are.
They're encouraged manifest those
talents partly because that would be
good for them spiritually and
psychologically,
but also because that would be a benefit
to the community,
right?
I mean talent's rare,
which people don't understand.
There's lots of different kinds of
talent,
but it's.
But in each domain it's rare and so it's
to everyone's benefit to exploit
talented people to the maximum possible
degree.
So even if you're just selfish,
you want to push for equality of
opportunity because the more talented
people there are out there,
the more cool stuff you get to have and
hopefully the more diverse and
interesting your life is so.
So you can pursue equality of
opportunity policies and the
Scandinavians have done that.
Especially trying to knock down barriers
for women in the workplace and by all
accounts,
by all standard theories,
the Scandinavian countries in places
like the Netherlands,
Canada to a slightly lesser degree,
um,
have done,
uh,
have gone farther than any other
countries in pursuing those policies.
Okay.
And,
and,
and part of the consequence of that is
that some of the differences between men
and women have been minimized.
So obviously there's far more women in
the workplace and there were 40 years
ago and in many occupations there's
actually dominance by women.
There's dominance in the universities,
there's dominance in the healthcare
fields and so women have poured into the
workplace and hypothetically there's
problems with that because it's put a
lot of stress on family structure.
But hypothetically that's for the best.
And because it gives people a broader
range of choices and it gives everyone
access to more talent.
So.
And then also if you look around the
world,
you see that one of the best predictors
of,
of the probability of economic
development in developing countries is
their attitude is the attitude in those
countries towards equal rights for
women.
And it looks causal,
the more positively the country is
predisposed to female rights,
the more likely they are to develop
economically.
And maybe that's because that indicates
that they're open to new ideas or
something like that are open to
transformation.
So okay,
so that's one kind of equality,
open up the playing field so that
everybody has a chance to compete and
cooperate and land and land where they
will.
But then the other kind of equality is
equality of outcome.
So and that's often described as equity
in today's language.
And so the ultimate equity Utopia would
be take every job,
every conceivable kind of job,
and then stratify that by every
conceivable level of authority within
every job and then ensure that every
single category of person is represented
in precise,
a proportion to their,
to their prevalence in the population.
So every job should be 50 percent women
and 50 percent man and say 13 percent
non western ethnic minority and whatever
that happens to be.
And then you could break that down and
so and otherwise,
there's evidence of systemic prejudice.
Okay?
Now first thing to say about that is
that's impossible.
And the reason it's impossible is
because there is no limit to the number
of ways that you can categorize people
into groups so you know,
you,
you know about sex and ethnicity and
race,
maybe those are the obvious ones,
but now you have gender and then you
have ethnicity and you know,
and then there's attractiveness and
intelligence and temperament and height
and age and socioeconomic background.
And I mean,
let's say there's 20,
but there's a lot more than that.
There's no possible way that you could
ever regulated society so tightly that
every single one of those groups was
equally represented in every single one
of those occupations at every single
level of the hierarchy.
That is what they want to concentrate
on.
The significant ones.
Men and women and race.
Oh yeah.
But who's to say those are the
significant ones?
That's the other thing.
It isn't even obvious that they are.
Because I would say that like a more
significant one is cognitive ability
because that's a way bigger predictor of
longterm life success than sex or race.
So I don't even think that we've
necessarily identified the canonical
groups.
We've just decided that gender and race
are the,
maybe they're the most obvious,
but isn't there a problem is that people
don't.
What they don't do is they don't take
in,
in terms of cognitive ability,
they don't get on a team.
They don't get on like there's people
that are sexist yet,
but there's.
It's very rare that someone is elitist
in terms of their cognitive ability.
Well,
hard to say Joe.
I mean I think one of the reasons that
elitist prejudice is a better word.
I don't know.
You could be right,
but look,
I think one of the reasons that like if
you.
Here's something that's kind of
confusing.
It makes sense now that I'm thinking
about.
Of course they are.
Well,
there's one thing that's quite peculiar
about the United States in that regard
is like most working class people,
let's say,
are far more irritated with the
intellectual elite than they are with
the wealthy elite and that's because
they think they could become wealthy and
they could,
but they don't think they could become
part of the intellectual elite.
And it isn't obvious to me that the
intellectual elite.
So those would be the liberal left
leaning types that dominate the media
and academia are particularly,
um,
positive in their,
in their attitudes towards the typical
working class person.
I think they're prejudiced and elitist.
I do believe that that's the case and I
think they're also,
um,
what would you call it?
Patronizing.
And I think that the typical working
class person say who voted for trump is
very,
very sensitive to that.
And so they're much more concerned with
the one percent who are the cognitive
leap than they are the one percent who
are the economic elite because at least
they think that's a game they could
play.
So anyways,
it was also because it was caricature is
right of the one percent of the
economically you just think of people
that are in these lofty positions that
are in control of the financial
institutions,
but the one percent of the
intellectually you think of in terms of
like some of the more preposterous you
hearing out of universities now and save
spaces and oh yeah,
there's that too.
There's two things that there's no,
well,
there's no appreciation on the part of
the intellectual elite for the
pathologies of rational of rationalism.
Right?
I mean,
there's no,
there's nothing stupider than a smart
person who went wrong.
You know,
like you,
you can tank on.
I've,
I've seen this in my clients,
you know,
frequently,
like if I have a particularly smart
client who's particularly disordered in
their personality,
that that's just,
that's often just,
that's so difficult.
It's almost unimaginable because there's
so little,
for example,
that one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What is your approach to handling
something like that?
Who's like super intelligent,
but yet completely their life is in
disarray?
Well,
you know,
I'm usually,
I usually take a very practical
approach,
like,
you know,
we try to identify,
because I start always in my therapy
practice,
always start with behavioral principles.
It's like,
okay,
well let's see if we can identify a few
areas,
you know,
through negotiation that are really
causing you grief and misery,
you know,
like,
what's,
what's wrong with your life as far as
you're concerned.
And so that often takes a lot of
discussion and then we might try to
figure out what's causing that.
And that's often very difficult to
figure out too because it might be Jesus
might be something physical,
you know,
you might be sick in some way because
depression has lots of depression,
is autoimmune related and anxiety can be
a side effect of all sorts of
physiological disorders are eating
improperly or sleeping badly or,
or not exercising,
you know,
enough to kind of keep yourself
regulated.
She tried to figure out what,
what's causing it.
And then you try to sketch out some
possible solution that we could both
test.
And then with the,
with the,
uh,
with the more intelligent ones,
you know,
often they can come up with all sorts of
reasons why none of this is going to
work or,
or a thousand reasons why.
Yeah.
Well usually a thousand reasons why none
of this is going to work.
And that with people like that,
sometimes it's useful to turn to their
dreams if they dream.
Because one of the things that's cool
about dreams is that even though they're
hard to interpret,
they never lie.
And so sometimes you can take someone
who's hyper rational and they'll have a
dream and they'll tell you the dream and
then you can work through an
interpretation which is a tricky
business.
And the dream will tell them something
and there's just no denying it.
It's like,
well,
it's a statement from nature.
So what are you going to do?
You gonna pretend that that's not the
case,
you know,
so,
so that's,
that's often extremely useful.
So,
so,
okay,
well,
back to the equality issue.
So,
okay,
so here's what's happened.
So psychologists have,
and this is what's putting a tale,
not in the tail of the Scandinavians.
Psychologists have come to a pretty
decent agreement about standard
personality models,
right?
So there's extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
openness and conscientiousness.
And they look fairly stable
cross-culturally.
And that was all done by asking
thousands of people,
hundreds and hundreds of questions and
then grouping them statistically.
So it was a theoretical.
Basically compute took computational
power and statistics to find out that
these are how traits group,
so I'm an extroverted,
people are sociable and happy and
neurotic people experience a fair bit of
negative emotion,
so that's the positive and negative
emotion.
Dimensions.
Agreeable people are maternal and
disagreeable people are competitive and
there's a fair bit of male female
difference.
They're conscientious.
People are dutiful and industrious and
orderly and the open people are creative
and so those are your basic five
dimensions.
Okay?
So that's been established and everyone
more or less agrees on it.
Now maybe there are seven dimensions and
we've got a questionnaire that that
breaks the five down into 10.
That's called understand myself,
but,
but basically there's good,
there's good consensus consent,
consensus on the five.
Okay,
so now soon as you have the five basic
traits,
you can ask some questions like,
well,
do men and women differ?
And so what you do is you just give the
questionnaire.
You can either fill it out yourself or
have other people fill it out on your
behalf.
So,
and it could be a teacher,
could be a parent,
you know,
and that's all been done and what you
find is there are systematic differences
between men and women and the biggest
differences are that women experience
more negative emotion and that and that
they're more agreeable than men,
so and that's borne out by the
psychiatric evidence because I'm higher
levels of negative emotion are
manifested in depression and anxiety and
women are diagnosed with higher levels
of depression and anxiety all around the
world and with agreeableness.
That's also borne out by the clinical
literature in some sense the medical
literature,
sociomedical literature because
disagreeable people are more likely to
be incarcerated because it's the best
predictor of being incarcerated even
though it's not a very good predictor
and men are incarcerated at about a 10
to one rate compared to women and are
more likely to be antisocial and conduct
disordered.
So the personality differences are
mirrored in the sociomedical literature.
Okay.
So,
so now,
so there are differences,
but then there's a question.
Are those differences a consequence of
socialization or the biological?
And the answer to that is tricky because
how much something is social and how
much it is biological actually depends
on the social circumstances.
So while here's an example,
if you have a society where no one has
enough to eat and people are starving,
then there's a huge cultural effect on
people's intelligence.
Let's say that's mediated by economic
factors,
even though it's got a biological
origin,
right?
This starvation.
So the relationship between biology and
cultures actually partly culturally
dependent.
So it makes it complicated.
But in any case,
here's how the scientists decided to
address this.
They thought,
well,
why don't we rank order countries by how
egalitarian they're social policies are,
which you can do with a fair degree of
reliability.
You know,
you've put the countries where women are
second class citizens at the bottom,
and you'd put the Scandinavian countries
at the top.
You can get good reliability across
raters for how you would rate those
countries.
And then look at the magnitude of the
differences between men and women,
by the egalitarian social policies.
And so then you'll find out,
and here's the hypothesis,
if the differences between men and women
are primary,
primarily social,
then as cultures become more
egalitarian,
men and women will become more alike.
That's not what happened.
The opposite happened.
The more egalitarian society and it
turns out the Richard This society,
because that's also been discovered now
the more different men and women become.
And so the differences are not huge.
So with agreeableness,
for example,
if you took the average man,
if took a typical man and a typical
woman out of the population just
randomly and you had to bet that the
woman was more aggressive than the man,
you'd be wrong 60 percent of the time.
So there's quite a bit of overlap,
right?
Because you'd be right 40 percent of the
time.
But the problem is is that a lot of
selection takes place at the extremes.
Maybe you're only concerned about
disagreeable people when they become
violent and maybe it's only the one in
50 most disagreeable person who's
violent and they're all men.
So you can have quite a bit of
similarity at,
at the average level and big differences
at the extremes and the extremes is
where people do things like,
like employment selection.
So the biggest difference that's been
discovered between men and women,
and this is the one that gets biggest in
the Scandinavian countries,
is the interest.
Men are more interested in things and
women are more interested in people and
it's a big difference.
It's one full standard deviation.
And so what that means is that if you're
a man,
you would have to be more interested in
people than 85 percent of men to be as
interested in people as the 50th
percentile a woman,
and you'd have to be more interested in
things than 85 percent of women to be as
interested in things as the typical man.
And what do you,
how do you define things?
Ob Gadgets,
gadgets,
things,
non non non animate things.
Cars,
yeah.
Yeah.
Tools,
you know,
technology,
right?
Stem fields.
Because the other thing that's happened
is that the more egalitarian the society
that fewer women go into the stem
fields,
the fewer that's interested.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so now this unraveled in a big way,
it's like this is a hugely a relevant
issue politically because it means that
you cannot have equality of opportunity
and equality of outcome at the same
time.
It's not possible because as you make
your society more egalitarian and you
open up the opportunity for equality of
outcome,
you increase how different men and women
are are and that changes their
occupational choice.
So if men are more interested
in things which they are by a
substantial margin than way more of them
are going to be engineers,
wouldn't that possibly support this idea
that in enforced model of,
of,
of equality would allow people to be
themselves more?
I mean this is almost what you're
saying.
Well that is the optimistic viewpoint.
Like,
well look,
it's so funny because the Swedish
foreign minister told me to go crawl
back under the rock that I came out from
under when I was in Scandinavia because
I was describing this,
these,
this science.
I've read that,
but I'm not exactly sure why.
Well,
she regards me as misogynists because I
think that there are.
Because I think because I've been
putting forward the evidence that there
are genuine differences between men and
women,
but she should be held accountable for
that because that's just a flippant
thing to say like you,
you,
you should have,
especially in a position of power like
she's in,
you should have a very specific argument
saying like for a leader to have such a
base thing to say such a crude,
dumb thing to say,
crawl back under the rock that you came
from.
Well,
I thought she was making a joke about
lobsters,
but I don't think she was.
The lobsters go onto rocks.
I guess they do the ground cracks.
Yeah.
The bigger lobsters have better rock.
That was another very interesting thing
in the Gq thing where the woman was
challenging you on your neurobiology,
your neurochemistry and that.
Yes.
Well,
hardly,
hardly any.
Hardly any psychologists understand that
serotonin is associated with
hierarchies.
It's like a truism.
It's been known for 30 years,
so we can definitely get back to that.
But I,
I'm very curious about this because this
idea of enforced equality,
right?
Ensuring that there is such a high
emphasis played a place on equality
equality,
that you have the equal amount of men,
the equal amount of women and the
opportunities are absolutely available
as much to women as they are to end.
This is enforced.
This creates an environment where
there's less resistance.
Now in an environment where there's less
resistance,
perhaps women don't feel as compelled to
say,
I'll show you that.
That is what seems to happen.
Well,
here's a look.
Here's an example.
So there are fewer women mathematicians
in the higher echelons.
Okay,
but here's something interesting about
mathematical ability.
First of all,
it's very rare,
so that's the first thing to keep in
mind.
Now it looks like if you look in junior
high that give mathematically gifted men
and males and females are approximately
as common.
Now there's a little bit of debate about
that because there is some evidence that
maybe at the very upper extremes there's
a male advantage just like there's a
male disadvantage at the low end because
the mail distribution for intelligence
might be flatter,
and so that's the greater married male
variability hypothesis.
There's been papers putting that forward
that had been retracted as a consequence
of pressure from politically correct
people,
even though greater male variability is
actually quite common in the animal
kingdom for a variety of reasons.
Men are more expendable,
that males are more expendable in some
ways,
or you could say that males are more
likely to purdue to pursue high risk,
high return strategies.
You can look at it either way and it's
certainly possible.
In any case,
the men,
the males in junior high who happened to
be mathematically gifted,
are less likely to also be verbally
gifted.
Whereas that doesn't seem to be the case
for the females,
and so if you're a male math nerd,
then math is pretty logical pathway for
you because you don't have as many other
options.
Whereas if you're a female math nerd,
you have other options because you're
less likely,
you're more likely to also be verbally
gifted and so that's enough to at least
in principle account for some of the
reasons why there are fewer women
mathematicians than men.
Mathematicians.
They have other options.
They have other options and there's lots
of complex.
There's lots of complex reasons like
this and so we have this reflects of
idea and this is very much the case
because this is like the core idea among
the feminist Neil Marxist types is that
if there's differences in outcome,
that's that's proof of prejudice and
that support for the idea of the
patriarchal tyranny and that's like the
core axiom of the radical left is the
patriarchal tyranny.
As far as I'm concerned.
That's that's God for them to
patriarchal tyranny.
It's like,
well,
if it turns out that many of these
differences in outcome between men and
women aren't a consequence of the
patriarchal tyranny,
in fact even get bigger.
When you reduce the tyrannical aspect of
the patriarch and even the patriarchal
aspect to it.
Then it makes that theory not only wrong
but opposite of the truth,
which is the worst kind of wrong.
And so you know,
if men are more likely to pursue careers
in the stem fields,
which seems to be the case under
conditions of optimal freedom for men
and women,
then that's going to drive income
disparities because the stem fields pay
more and they pay more.
Partly because they're scalable,
like it's really hard to scale care for
people.
You know,
like if you work in a daycare,
you're going to care for three infants,
you're not going to care for 50 because
you can't,
it's not scalable.
But if you're like a software designer,
it's infinitely scalable.
And so there's,
there's a much wider range of possible
of possibility for generating much
larger,
much larger income pools and much larger
pools of wealth,
you know,
and men are also more likely to work
longer hours.
And if you work 10 percent longer hours,
you make 40 percent more money.
There's a nonlinear return on.
That's good thing for everybody who's
listening to know if you have a job,
you want to be the guy or the woman
who's working that extra 10 percent
because the return on that is non
linear.
So that's a really useful thing to know.
Men are more likely to work outside.
They're more likely to work in dangerous
businesses.
They're more likely to run fulltime
businesses rather than part time
businesses.
And uh,
they're more likely to move in pursuit
of their career goals.
And that all contributes to differences
in and in,
in Uber drivers,
they're,
they make seven percent more money
because they drive faster so and so
anyways.
That's not good though.
I'll know.
But it's a high risk,
high return issue.
It's a pattern mail.
It's common,
it's more risk,
there's more risk in it.
So there's more return as long as you
don't get hurt.
And I think that's a pretty common male
pattern is there's more risk is there's
more return as long as you don't get
hurt.
Problem seems to be when discussing
these things in any way romanticizing or
glorifying male behavior or putting any
emphasis whatsoever on their being a,
a positive aspect to a lot of the things
that we think of as being negative,
like aggression or ambition or,
or,
or competition.
And Yeah.
Yeah.
Well the competition amongst men is
fine.
Competition with men against women is
often thought of as cruel.
Yeah.
Well that.
Yes.
Well,
and,
and there's a certain amount of reason
for that as well because obviously
physical competition is,
it's easy for that to border on.
Cruel.
This is why we were shocked.
We were talking before the show that
instead of calling people,
men and women when referring to like
because there's this very disturbing in
my opinion,
trend of transgender women entering into
these competitions now with women who
are biologically female and dominating
them and that instead of calling people,
men and women,
let's dispense with them.
You can just say,
yeah,
you can be a man or woman.
That's your choice and you can change it
whenever you want,
so your man or a woman and that's your
choice,
but we're going to have a new rule which
is that if you have an x,
y chromosome,
so you're an x,
y person or an xx person than if you're
an x,
x person,
x,
y person.
You don't get to engage in physical
combat with an x,
y person.
Yes.
Men or one x person mass.
Yeah.
How would that.
If you're x,
Y,
you can't engage in physical combat with
Xs,
right?
X Ys cannot hit xxs.
How's that?
And maybe they can't run in cotton
running contests against them and maybe
they can't play tennis against them
knowing within.
And maybe that's just reasonable is
reason.
Yes,
it is certainly reasonable,
but if you talk about that,
especially someone like you was,
you were against this bill that was
going to enforce these pronouns and the
compelling the use of these pronouns
that your thought to be transphobic
person because you feel like there maybe
should be some rational discussion about
the physical limitations of certain body
structures because that's what it is.
If you're talking about my field of
business,
you're talking about combat.
I've been involved in combat sports my
whole life and there is a difference.
And it's not to say that females aren't,
aren't competent and I mean I had Miriam
Nakamoto on yesterday,
she's a good friend of mine.
She's an eight time world champion and
she's a monster,
but she doesn't fight against men and
you shouldn't fight against men,
although she's
probably could beat a bunch of them.
Right?
It's not.
She shouldn't have to.
And she's a tough woman.
Can beat a variety of men.
Oh yeah.
Really tough man can beat all women.
Yes.
Right.
So that's the problem.
That's the reality.
And that is definitely,
you know,
and people don't like to hear these
things and they don't want to pretend
that you can even out the playing field
with hormones.
No,
you can even at a little there certain
things like I've always said you,
if you gave brock Lesnar a sex change
and put them in a dress,
he's going to run through every woman
that's ever lived in the history of
women.
There's not a single woman is going to
be able to deal with that bone structure
and that,
that mind that that guy has had with
testosterone pumping through it for 39
years.
So she's.
It's just preposterous that even to have
to have the discussion.
It's so,
so absolutely ridiculous.
The one thing that I was attacked on
more than anything in my entire life is
saying that I think it's ridiculous to
have a trans woman compete against women
and mixed martial arts.
I was like,
you want to have them do it in chess.
You want to have them do it in something
that's nonphysical.
Sure.
You want them to be a woman.
Yes.
Okay.
You want them to be recognized as a
woman,
you sure,
but it's Mr.
compelling people like,
here's one that's going up lately.
If you don't want to date a trans woman
than you are some sort of a bigot.
But if you're a man,
you know,
even if you want a family,
you know what you remember in,
in,
in a brave new world,
in Huxley's book,
It was considered immoral to reject
anyone sexual advances because it was
prejudicial.
Oh yes.
And the thing is,
it is prejudicial.
That's the thing now,
but the seeds.
So that makes the question even more
interesting because the question is at
what point do you have the right to your
prejudices and what?
One of the things that we seem to cling
to,
and I would say rightly,
is that we're allowed to be prejudice
when it comes to who we interact with
sexually and then and who we choose as
friends.
And that's right.
That's the right to association.
And you know,
you said only up to a certain point.
Well that's.
This is because this,
this new logic is kind of leaking into
your sexual preference.
Now like if you have a problem with
someone being overweight,
yeah.
Then you're a scientist or something
like that.
Like what is that?
Well,
the thing is is that you can't have
preferences without having prejudices
course.
Right?
So that's a big.
That's a big issue.
So what does that mean?
You don't get to have any preferences.
How's that gonna work out in terms of
like what you like to eat or what kind
of films you enjoy or what kind of books
you read.
You're allowed to have these
preferences.
But when it comes to what you're
sexually attracted to,
there's new emphasis now trying to draw
that line and say like wait,
but it's preposterous.
People that are pushing this and I've
almost everybody's pushing back,
but I find it interesting when these
things come logical,
it's a logical conclusion to all these
other things that have been happening
because that is where the rubber hits
the road.
It's like,
you know,
when,
when I,
when I.
Well,
I've seen this in debates that I've had
publicly where people,
you know,
talk about prejudice and I've pointed
out to them that they have prejudicial
attitudes with regards to their sexual
preferences because they don't just
sleep with anyone who asks them.
Right?
So it's like,
well,
how is that not a prejudice?
Well,
of course it's a prejudice.
Well then the question is under what
circumstances are prejudices justifiable
and that's a conversation we don't like
to have because we believe that there
are no circumstances whatsoever under
which prejudices are are acceptable.
There's a big difference between
prejudice and discrimination.
I think those two get conflated.
Yes,
there is a big difference between
prejudice and discrimination and all
totally discrimination has to do with
setting your standards in relationship
to the task at hand.
That's what you'd hope for that.
That's the appropriate forms of
discrimination.
Rats,
that's like intelligence.
Sure.
Everything is.
Everything isn't the same about
everything all the time.
So you discriminate,
you rank order things and you need to
rank order them even to pursue things
that are valuable.
This is one of the problems with the
people who are so anti hierarchy,
like the like the radical leftists,
while there shouldn't be hierarchies,
it's like,
okay,
then why do something that that argument
is so foolhardy that it's.
It's difficult to take seriously,
but you do have to engage in it and I
think when you engage in it,
it's really fascinating to watch because
it's like you're playing a game of chess
with someone only has a couple of
pieces.
They have this strong move that they do,
but you've got all these other pieces
and you're like,
well,
let's just keep this game going until
this comes to this logical conclusion,
which is checkmate.
There's hierarchies all throughout
nature.
It doesn't mean people should suppress
people,
doesn't mean people shouldn't have
rights.
It doesn't mean people should enforce
themselves or force themselves on other
folks.
That's not what it means.
It also doesn't mean that the
hierarchies,
especially if they're human hierarchies
done well or or or that they're only.
That's right.
Not that they're good necessarily or
that they're predicated going power,
like one of the most pathological
elements of the postmodern types.
Especially people like food is their
insistence that all hierarchical
structures are predicated on power and
that there's nothing other than power
and that's completely preposterous.
I mean,
I use examples of plumbers in my
lectures more recently because it's
rather comical,
so like,
well,
on what basis do you hire a plumber?
So imagine that there's a hierarchy of
plumbers ranging from very successful to
very unsuccessful.
Okay.
And you say,
well,
what makes plumbers successful?
Well,
the power theory would,
would imply that there are roving bands
of mafioso plumbers who like come
pounding on your door at three in the
morning and tell you that if you don't
get their particular posy to fix your
pipes leaking or not,
that they're going to come and burn down
your house.
Of course,
that's completely.
It's completely absurd.
When you go to hire someone like a
plumber,
well the first thing you want to know
his reputation,
can they actually fix a pipe because you
actually want your pipe fixed and then
you want to know,
well,
do they deal with you fairly?
And part of what's tangled up in that in
all likelihood is do they deal with
their employees fairly because that's
going to make their business function
properly.
And so the hierarchy of plumbers,
which is part of the patriarchal
tyranny,
is almost entirely predicated on
competence.
And almost every enterprise in the west
is like that.
Because I keep wondering,
well,
where the hell is this patriarchal
tyranny?
Like is it massage therapists?
Is it nurses?
Most nurses are female.
If you get females organized into a
hierarchy,
which you do in nursing,
is that all of a sudden,
is that part of the patriarchal tyranny
or is it the fact that no,
all those people are women?
Does that mean it's no longer?
Well,
it still hierarchy.
Is it no longer a tyranny?
Is it no longer patriarchal?
Like is it patriarchal only because
there's men in it?
Or is it patriarchal because it's a
hierarchy of this stuff is so incoherent
that it just all you have to do is think
about it and,
and that hasn't been done to any great
degree and it just dissolves in your
hands.
That's what I'm saying is that if you're
entering into a job straight out of
college,
you leave university and now you're
entering into,
you know,
your first year in the workplace,
it's,
it's just a natural fact of life that
there's going to be people that are
further ahead in this race than you
because they're better at what they do.
Some of the more experienced and more
education.
Some of them are more crooked and snitch
too as well because the.
But it's the.
It's the agreeing.
Everyone agreeing that this is a game.
Yeah.
This is some sort of a competition and
you're going to have hierarchies in
competitions.
You're going to have people who when
you're going to have people who do
better no matter what the thing,
so that's the fundamental issue.
As soon as you said,
we could look at it this way,
as soon as you.
Let's assume people have problems,
everybody can agree on that,
then we could assume that people would
like solutions to those problems,
so we could agree on that.
Then we could say,
well then if you implement a solution
socially,
so with other people,
then you're going to cooperate and
compete in relationship to the solution
and that's instantly going to produce a
hierarchy because no matter what the
problem is,
some people are going to be better at
solving it than others and then if you
have any sense,
you put the people who are good at
solving it at the forefront because then
they solve it faster and cheaper and
better and then everybody benefits,
but then you get a hierarchy,
right?
The people who solve those problems get
financial incentive to solve those
problems.
Yes.
And they it and they do that because the
rest of us are greedy and desperate.
It's like,
you know,
we want the people who are good at
solving the problems to keep solving
them,
and so what we're trying to do is to
reward them so that they'll keep doing
it even if it's difficult to give them
some status and extraordinarily if,
if necessary.
Yes.
When you look at the people that are the
head of giant industry,
the ceos of super successful companies,
they're the ones that have the giant
yachts and the big houses and this is
the incentive for people to try to get
to that position and the idea that
there's no incentive and that there
should be no incentive,
but yet you're still gonna have all this
innovation is ridiculous.
It's not how it works.
It's not how human beings work.
If human beings are going to work really
hard,
there has to be some sort of a reward
and it can't be an equal voice and then
then what you could say like,
so okay,
so the right that that would be roughly
speaking,
a conservative position,
and then you can take a left wing
position that's reasonable and you can
say,
yes,
there are hierarchies,
but we have to stay awake because they
can degenerate into power hungry tyranny
so that it's no longer competence.
It's political machination and game
playing and tyranny that that produced
the positional positional
differentiation.
So we got to stay awake to that and so
we got to criticize the hierarchies.
Not the fact of hierarchy,
but the structure of hierarchy so they
stay honest and then we also have to be
careful because when you do set up a
hierarchy,
then a lot of people collect at the
bottom.
That's the necessary consequence of a
few people collecting at the top and so
then you have to be concerned about
those people at the bottom and so
there's a variety of things that you
would do to express that concern is one,
you might want to have a lot of
hierarchies so that people have
different talents,
could play different games and a complex
society is pretty good at that,
but you're still gonna have people who
stack up at the bottom of all
hierarchies.
Right?
And those are going to be people who are
sick mentally and physically and maybe
people who are cognitively impaired or
you know or have experienced some kind
of catastrophe in their life.
And then you,
you want to set up your system so that
those people don't suffer unduly.
Partly because that's bad and partly
because that destabilizes your whole
society.
And so you could say,
well that's the left's place is to speak
for the speak on behalf of the unjustly
dispossessed and the rights position is
to stabilize and maintain functional
hierarchies and encourage competition
and encourage competition that's of
benefit to the whole and,
and to the individuals within the
competition.
And then the political dialogue is a
continual discussion between the left
and the right saying,
well,
you know,
at this hierarchies getting a little too
steep and a little too rigid and,
and,
and well.
And that's,
for me,
that's also the fundamental reason for
the necessity of free speech.
It's because that's the only way to
discuss this.
It is the only,
that's the only way of working it out
and it is the case you need,
you're going to produce hierarchies if
you're going to pursue things of value
socially going to pre produce
hierarchies and they're necessary.
And there's also,
I have a giant issue with the concept
that these things are mutually
exclusive,
that you can't have competition and also
have a good social environment.
I think that's preposterous idea.
I mean,
one of the things I really like about
the psychologist,
Sean Piaget,
who said I would say the world's
foremost expert on games is that he did
a very careful analysis of say,
competitive games.
Okay,
so let's take hockey or soccer.
It doesn't matter.
Same example.
You say,
well,
because people now they have kids play
these games and don't keep score,
which of course the kids keep score
because they're not stupid like the
adults.
But you know,
while we
can't have it be competitive.
Okay,
so let's take it apart.
It's like,
well,
is hockey a competitive game or a
cooperative game?
Okay,
well,
so first of all,
everyone's trying to do the same thing
that's cooperative.
It's not like half the people are
playing chess and another,
you know,
a third of them brought a basketball and
two of them are boxing and well
sometimes they do in hockey boxing in a
corner,
but everyone's trying to do the same
thing.
So that's cooperative.
Okay.
Everyone plays their position.
That's cooperative.
They all followed the same rules.
That's cooperative,
right?
So,
so there's competition,
but it's nested inside a fundamental
structure of cooperation.
And the cooperation is the cooperation
is the basis of the game itself.
Let's all arbitrarily agree that it's
important to put this black disk in the
net,
which is to get your aim right and then
let's cooperate within our teams to do
that because we're going to pass and
we're going to,
we're going to pass each other and we're
also going to work so that each of us is
a good player,
but so that we all work for the
betterment of our team because we want
to win games across multiple games.
So that's also cooperative.
And then you want to interact with your,
your enemies,
let's say the other team in a way that's
indicative of good sportsman ship so
that the entire league can flourish.
And to think of that as competitive is
absolutely.
It's so,
um,
I,
there's no other way of describing it
than stupid.
That's what it is.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an ignorant unit,
dimensional analysis.
It's put forward by someone who's
reflexively opposed to anything that
smacks of competition and who isn't
thinking it through at all.
They're denying the benefits of
competition and the fact that they
reaped those benefits of competition by
enjoying the products that are created
by these corporations.
Yes.
Well,
it's very hypocritical and.
that's for sure.
That's called a performative
contradiction.
It's like,
well,
I'd like to.
I like to complain about left wing
issues on my iphone.
Right,
exactly.
You know,
it's like,
well,
yeah,
fair enough.
But you know,
used to have a little gratitude for the
fact that you've got your iphone to
complain about and those and those
organizations,
those corporations are unbelievably
competitive unblend.
They fall apart almost instantly when
that competition starts,
stops being a,
an issue because then there's no
constraint on the behavior of the
behavior of the system.
So yes,
and you know,
the,
the issue with men,
I think with young men,
and this is one of the things I've been
trying to address is that if your
fundamental presupposition is that our
culture is a patriarchal tyranny,
which is an appalling presupposition
along with the idea that the best way of
looking at history is that it,
it was the oppression,
the continual oppression of women by
men.
Which is also something that I regard as
absolutely reprehensible doctrine.
Then,
okay,
so it's a patriarchal tyranny,
but in their defense that did exist.
There has been continual oppression of
women.
It's just not the only thing that's
happened.
Well,
there's been women that have been
revered.
There's been women that have been
celebrated.
There's been women that
have accomplished great things,
but there's been a lot of oppression.
So if they concentrate primarily on that
oppression and that's their main point
of study and that's the thing they want
to talk about all the time.
They kind of have a point in the fact
that if you're looking at all the events
that have ever taken place,
there's a significant number of them
that have been women being oppressed.
That's a real thing.
I don't know if there's more women
who've been oppressed than men who've
been oppressed.
Very good point.
So I would say that the entire history
of.
I mean you look at it this way,
is that we oppress ourselves personally
with our own malevolence and stupidity.
And then we're all oppressed by the kind
of the crushing hand of the social
world.
That molds us in one way and not in
another,
and then of course nature is doing her
best all the time to give birth to us,
but also to kill us and take us out,
and so there's this endless like there's
this endless,
what would you call it,
vulnerability that characterizes our
existence psychologically and socially
and naturally and I would say a hundred
and 50 years ago that was even more
intense than it was now.
You know,
because the typical person in the west
lived on less than a dollar a day before
18,
95,
and so the way I think that we should
view the history of the world is that
men and women labored under virtually
impossible conditions for the entire
bulk of human evolution and they did
their best to cooperate and to compete,
but to cooperate so that they had some
modicum,
some possibility of a modicum of
security and satisfaction and that
that's the right framework.
And then within that,
of course there's power games that are
played by people who are corrupt.
Yeah.
Within that,
there's horrible events.
Of course they're taking place,
but there's a.
there's a massive amount of hypocritical
thinking when you are criticizing the
actions of so many people talking about
how many people are complicit in these
things while you're carrying around a
phone that's made by someone who gets a
dollar a day.
I was talking to a journalist in
Slovenia,
a who was a lefty and not a very
sophisticated one,
and she was talking about the one
percent and I said,
well,
you know that if you make more than
$32,000
a year that you're part of the one
percent.
She said,
well,
what do you mean?
I said,
well,
that's the worldwide statistic.
It's like,
so you're part of the one percent.
Well,
she didn't.
First of all,
she said,
well,
I don't believe that statistic,
and I thought,
well,
that's fine.
You can look it up yourself.
But what was so interesting was that for
her,
that characterization,
the one percent victimizers was only
relevant within the confines of her
national border.
Right?
Soon as I said,
well,
no,
it's all you have to do is expand that
out a little bit and you're the problem
and not the solution.
Then that was,
that was completely untenable for her
exam.
She couldn't include herself in the
population of victimizers even though
she lives in a Western country and she's
a well paid journalist and she's lived a
very privileged life,
so to speak by historical standards to
someone living in the Congo or something
or or or anybody living anywhere in the
entire history of the human race
opportunity.
Yeah,
for sure.
If you make $34,000
today,
you absolutely are in the top one
percent of everybody who's ever though,
definitely.
Well,
of course.
Of course.
Yes,
yes,
definitely.
Especially given what you can buy with
it.
The only reason denied that is because
it doesn't fit what you've come into.
The argument with,
it doesn't.
It doesn't fit your pre k,
the pre predisposed notion that you have
though your idea that you're.
It's so rigid.
This idea that you are not one of the
ones that's just carrying that iphone
with that laptop and all these different
things that you enjoy that are created
by these corporations that you.
You support them financially,
but yet they're the ones that are
destroying this earth.
These are the ones that you're rallying
against these,
the ones that you hate against.
Yeah.
Well,
the victim,
victimizer narrative only works if you
assume that you're a victim.
Right,
and as soon as you assume that you're a
victimizer,
well then it's not so much fun.
One of the things I wrote the forward
for the new version of of Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag archipelago,
the abridged version.
It came out November first and I was
trying to figure out why the Russian
revolution went wrong so rapidly because
it went wrong right from the beginning
and they.
They sold units and quotes.
This guy named,
I think his name was Walter Lapsis,
if I remember correctly.
He got the part right anyways,
and he said,
when you're interrogating a member of
the bourgeoisie to decide whether they,
whether they constitute an enemy of the
state,
you don't give any credibility to such
niceties as individual guilt or
innocence.
All you care about is their group and
their background and their economic
status,
and if they're in the wrong group,
the bourgeoisie,
then that's it.
That's the end of them and and comments,
not just the end of them,
but the end of their children and their
grandchildren as well,
and lots.
This was eventually executed by Stalin.
Somebody wrote me and just told me that
after I wrote the forward,
but one of the things I figured out was
this,
and this is really worth thinking about
man.
So the intersection will claim is that
you know,
each person has more than one group
identity.
So fundamentally if you're going to
calculate their victim status,
then you have to calculate it across all
the different groups that they might be
victims in.
And so you know,
maybe,
Oh,
who knows,
a native American is one form of victim
in this line of thinking,
but a native American victim is female
is like twice the victim or however you
would calculate that mathematically.
It's like,
okay,
and maybe you have,
maybe you can be put into six different
groups.
We already talked about that a little
bit,
but here's the bloody rub.
If I put you in six groups in one of
those groups,
you're a victimizer.
You can bloody well bed on it.
And then here's the next rule.
If you're a victimizer among any
possible dimension of analysis,
then it's the gulag for you.
And so that's the fundamental danger of
that group identity,
victimizer,
victim,
new narrative is that you
fragment your identity of multiple
dimensions.
You'll find out that you're a victimizer
and then everyone,
then everyone's a criminal and then
everyone's guilty.
That's exactly what happened in Russia.
And then you think,
well,
wait a minute.
There were a bunch of people who were
really compassionate about the poor.
It's like let's say just for the sake of
argument,
that at the beginning of the Russian
revolution,
that 20 percent of the communists were
really concerned about the poor.
Maybe we could say 50 percent just to be
arbitrary about it.
The other 50 percent were jealous and
resentful about anyone who anything more
than they did.
All right.
Now that you put those two groups,
head to head in a battle for four years
and see who's standing at the end.
Even if you are one of those utopians
who actually cares for the dispossessed
when the revolution comes,
you can bloody well be sure that your
head's going to be first on the chopping
block because the people who are
motivated by hate are going to be a lot
more vicious in their attempts to
eradicate.
Then you're going to be,
what would you call it,
effective in your,
in your attempts to save that whole
game.
That whole identity politics game that
is dangerous beyond belief and it's
predicated fundamentally on resentment
and the desire to devolve people back
into tribal antagonism.
I think it's so important that you talk
about it this way and I think it's
really interesting what I see the
resistance.
Do you talk about it this way and how
many people are unwilling to look at it
as this multilevel historical sort of
record that you could look and see how
this played out and you can look and see
what's going on right now with these
control games that people are playing
socially and that they are enforcing
certain types of behavior in certain
ways of thinking and then trying to
reign in earnings and raw rally against
capitalism and support communism and
socialism and doing so in this sort of
weird,
trendy way without understanding the
full scope of the historical
implications when it's been tried in the
past and that it's not as simple as
like,
you know,
uh,
you got this and Ryan thing doing.
You're looking at this world.
DEB's,
you know,
capitalism against socialism.
It's good people who care about folks
versus people who are ruthless.
It's not that,
well,
that isn't even how capitalism doesn't
even work like that.
You know,
that managers are more stressed by the
people they manage than the people they
manage our stress by their managers.
I mean,
then think about it,
right?
Just to all,
you have to think about that for a
minute.
It's like you're an employee and you
have a manager and the managers a bit of
a jerk,
let's say,
but there's 28,
you know,
so there's like you're kind of one slash
20th oppressed by the manager,
but now you're the manager and you're
managing 20 people and you're
responsible for them and we're assuming
that you're not a psychopath and you're
probably not because he probably
wouldn't have been able to get to be a
manager if you're a psychopath because
psychopaths generally aren't very
successful and they have to keep moving
as people figure out who they are.
So the idea that like psychopathic power
is a good route to power in a
functioning organization is a stupid
theory.
There are some organizations that are
pathological enough so that works,
but they don't last very long either.
So you're the
manager and you're a decent human being
and you've got 20 people who are
dependent on you and at least two of
those people are real trouble.
Like they are serious trouble and
they're there.
They're your concern all the time.
And so you see this as and as people
move up the corporate hierarchies,
you think while they have more and more
power,
it's like,
yeah,
but not really.
They have more and more responsibility
and their behavior is actually monitored
with increasing severity.
It's like you're quite constrained in
most high level positions of authority
in complex organizations like you have
to behave pretty damn carefully or
you're going to get yourself in trouble
very,
very quickly.
We'll start today.
I think that that wasn't necessarily the
case a decade ago or two decades ago.
It was less the case unless the case
today it's far easier to get called out
on things,
but he but even so like you know,
even even 20 years ago,
like if you didn't treat your customers
properly and carefully reciprocally in
longterm relationships,
you are going to be a failure and you
know,
in,
in any corporation that,
that produces anything of any value.
I mean the production is one thing.
So you have to be competent at the
production,
but you have to be in constant
communication with your,
with your buyers and foster those
relationships personally.
Because there's intense competition and
if those personal relationships aren't
of high quality,
then your business fails and one of the
things I really learned because I spent
a lot of time with business people as
well as academics,
is that business people do a tremendous
amount of socialization compared to
academics.
Academics can judge each other's work
more or less on the basis of its
scientific merit and so they don't have
to establish personal relationships to
the same degree,
but business people are always
wondering,
well,
can I trust you?
Can we enter into a reciprocal
relationship that's going to be a mutual
benefit over the long run,
and so they're testing people out
socially all the time and if you're not
capable of reciprocating honestly over
some decades say,
then you're going to screw things up in
an absolutely horrible way.
It's one of the reasons why they like to
use golf as a matter of.
Yes,
exactly.
That's as Dr is two things.
One,
you get to see how someone handles
competition and we get to see if they
cheat.
Yeah,
because people do cheat and golf.
You know,
it was an interesting story.
A good friend of mine,
his,
uh,
his dad was playing golf with this man
and his wife was there as well,
and the wife saw the dad moved the,
saw this man that he was playing golf
with,
move the ball and she said,
do not go into business with this man.
Did not trust this man.
He's a cheater.
He cheated at golf and he thought it was
not that big a deal.
It's like,
it's just a game of golf.
I'm just like,
no,
this is a big deal.
It turns out the guy was a fucking
criminal.
Just took a while to find out.
I mean,
he wound up doing a lot of other things
that how you do some things is
oftentimes how you do everything.
Yeah.
Well that's why people are so interested
in games.
Yes.
You know,
because gave who a person really is well
games.
This is again why I'm such an admirer of
Piaget because he knew very well that
game is a microcosm
of reality.
That's why we like being.
You have to have an explanation for why
people like games.
I've been talking about this a lot in my
lectures too,
is you think,
well,
you know any game,
like any competitive game,
soccer's a good example.
It's basically a hunting game because
you're.
You're firing a projectile at a target.
Okay,
so the targets,
the goal and the projectiles,
the ball,
but it doesn't matter is that so you
have.
You have teams that are figuring out how
to hunt properly.
Then you think,
well to hunt properly you have to put
the ball in the net as many times as you
possibly can.
So and so you organize yourself in a
hierarchy to facilitate that,
but then that's,
that's not the whole story because you
tell your kids,
doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
And the kids all freaked out about that
because he doesn't know what you mean.
And he says,
well,
what do you mean doubt?
I'm trying to supposed to try to win.
And you say,
I don't know what I mean,
but it's,
it's still true.
But here's what you mean is that if
you're in a league,
you're not trying to win the soccer
game,
you're trying to win the soccer
championship and to win the championship
you have to win a whole bunch of games
and the rules to win a whole bunch of
games aren't the same as the rules to
win one game.
You know,
like you could go flat out as the
Premadonna and bend and bend the rules
and cut corners and exhaust every one
and win the game and then lose the next
three because that's a stupid medium to
longterm strategy.
Or You could be like the superstar and
hog the ball at the time and never give
your teammates a chance to develop.
But then you're injured and you're team
is out.
So those,
that's a stupid strategy too.
So you think,
well,
what you have to do to win the
championship is that you have to
organize your team so that the best
players lead,
but that everybody gets developed and
that you play the medium to longterm
game in a fair way,
in a fair and decent way.
Okay?
So you think,
well that's how you win a championship.
I talked to a coach a while back and he
said one of the things he did to select
athletes was to watch what happened when
they scored a goal and if they were
celebrating on their own,
you know,
in sort of an egotistical way,
then that wasn't such a good sign,
but if they scored a goal or a touchdown
or whatever it was and their whole
entire team came in and bombed them and
then like lifted them up on their
shoulders and he thought that guy is an
athlete because not only can he put the
goal,
put the ball in the net,
but he does it in a way that benefits
the entire team and that's the person
you weren't around for the long run.
And so then the goal isn't just to put
the ball in the goal.
The goal is to put the ball in the goal
the the largest number of times while
simultaneously benefiting as many as you
have your fellow players as you can.
Although no,
I think
that's a great strategy.
I don't think that's necessarily the
meaning of it doesn't matter if you win
or lose,
it's how you play the game.
I think what I don't think people think
of it in terms of like a longterm
strategy for championship leagues will
take when they're saying it doesn't
matter whether you win or lose,
it's how you play the game.
Meaning don't cheat.
Do your
best and learn.
Right?
But I think that's right.
While learn how to handle failure,
learn how to handle victory will also
learn from the experience itself.
Like if you make a mistake and you,
you're trying your hardest,
but you make an error because someone
has a counter to that.
Then you learn from that.
That's how you play the game.
You play it so stupidly and you don't
think and you win just because you got
lucky.
That's not as good as playing
intelligently and expanding your skills
and losing yes because the other people
are superior and then you learn from the
fact that they figured out a way to have
solutions to all the problems that you
presented this.
Okay,
so,
so one of the things that you're
pointing out is that while you're
playing,
you want to be expanding your range of
skills so that you get better at playing
the next game,
but then you think,
well even the soccer championship isn't
the whole game,
right?
Because your life is a whole series of
games,
of,
of championships,
of different types of ideas.
The championships will come if you
continue to excel and get excellent.
Yes.
And also if people invite you to play.
So there's both of those are the two
things.
So that's the goal,
right?
The goal isn't to put the ball in the
net,
the goal is to get excellent and to be
invited to play.
And the mechanism is that you put the
ball in the goal and that makes sense.
See that helps explain why people find
competitive sports.
So unbelievably compelling because you
can be cynical about it and you can say,
well look,
there's 50,000
people there watching,
you know,
somebody kick a,
uh,
a spheroid object into a net who the
hell cares like,
and,
but,
but that's not the issue.
What you're,
what you are in fact doing is you're
going there to watch people develop
expertise and to learn to play
reciprocally in a noble and ethical
manner and all of that sport when it's
done properly is a direct physical
incarnation of that ethic and so it's
not surprising that that's why people
get so excited when they see an athlete
do something.
Imagine the best thing that you can see
at a sports event is someone who does
something.
I'm purely in the spirit of fair play
and in a manner that's unbelievably
excellent,
right?
Wayne Gretzky was very good at that,
Because he was an excellent,
excellent sportsmen and also
unbelievably skilled and so people loved
them and that's,
that's perfect because he was,
he was a player who played the game,
like it was more important to play it
properly then to win and he was on the
top of his game at the same time.
And that's what you want to be
enlightened and cut corners.
That's right.
There is no cutting corners.
Yeah.
And so that's very cool.
And you see a very high order ethic
emerge out of that.
You want to be the kind of player that
everybody.
I kind of wrote about that in 12 rules
for life when you know,
because part of my advice in rule five
was not to let your kids do anything
that makes you dislike them,
and that's part of the idea there is
that you know,
if you're really on the side of your
children,
you help them develop in a manner that
makes them eminently desirable to other
children and capable of interacting
properly with adults
because then the whole world opens up to
them.
Now it's a really and then you do that.
The thing that's cool about that too is
that this is what makes the postmodern
and the Marxists types so wrong,
is that your best strategy for success
in life isn't the exercise of power.
It's a really counterproductive
strategy.
Doesn't even work very well for advanced
animals.
Your best strategy is skill and
reciprocity,
so when there's a real high order ethic
in that that has nothing to do,
so the idea that our hierarchies are
predicated on power and they're corrupt
because of that,
and the whole world is a battleground
between hierarchies of different power
hierarchies and it's winner take all and
you know the devil take the hindmost.
That's just completely inappropriate.
Psychologically.
There's a real situation where you
very rarely find people who excel at
competition and who have benefited from
competition,
who are against competition,
and you very rarely find people who have
no skill in competition at all and who
have never engaged in,
have shied away from it their whole life
that support it and and believe that
it's an important part of our culture.
I think people want,
they want to believe and they want to
support things that reinforce their idea
of how they're living their life
correctly and if,
if they shy away from competition,
if it makes them nervous,
if they've never excelled at it,
if it doesn't feel right to them,
if it makes them uncomfortable,
they want to feel like there some better
way.
And this is one of the things that leads
young,
sensitive,
kind,
compassionate people towards socialism
and this concept that capitalism and,
and any form of competition at all
ultimately,
ultimately is going to lead to a few
people hogging up all the wealth and
dominating all the people.
Well,
the other thing that's kind of sad about
that is that no matter what system you
set up that outcome,
you know,
like if you look at the prieto
distribution,
so if that's the distribution of wealth,
you'll find that in every society that
we know of,
whether it's capitalist or socialist or
communist for that matter,
a small proportion of the people have a
disproportionate amount of the
resources.
So.
So you.
So the other thing that I've been trying
to explain in my lectures is that if you
were really concerned about the
dispossessed and the poor,
you wouldn't put hierarchical
dispossession at the feet of capitalism
because it's a way worse problem than
that,
you know,
because the Marxists types,
they think,
well,
if we didn't have capitalism,
there wouldn't be hierarchies and there
wouldn't be dispossession.
And that's complete bloody rubbish
because the problem of hierarchy and the
problem of dispossession is way deeper
than the problem of capitalism.
So like if you look at Neolithic grave
sites way before there was capitalism,
you see that a small number of people
are buried with all the gold.
So the,
the fact of,
of dis dis unequal distribution of,
that's his oldest,
that's as old as hierarchies are old.
It's unbelievably old.
And so for the leftists to take an
anticapitalist position and assume that
that's going to be a benefit to the
dispossessed is an idea that's at least
145 years out of date as far as I'm
concerned.
But we do want to discourage tyranny.
We do want to keep keep that.
We want to keep someone from
accumulating so much wealth that they
dominate the world and have a
disproportionate effect on culture and
do things that are detrimental.
That could be in fact detrimental for
decades and decades to come.
I mean,
to this day.
Well that's where you have a balance of
powers in the United States because.
Yeah.
Well the thing is it's not the case like
the fact that you can't characterize the
West as a patriarchal tyranny doesn't
mean that hierarchies don't become
tyrannical.
Sometimes they do and yeah.
And we have to be alert to that and
that's been known for a very long time.
So is it fair to say that the West has
some aspects of a hierarchy,
hierarchical tyranny?
Of course,
of course.
And I would say that's a mythological
true is so like the way that society is
represented in our deep narrative
structures is always twofold.
There's a wise king in a tyrannical king
and they're pitted against each other.
And your job is to amplify the wise king
and keep the tyrant under control.
That's the evil advisor to the king,
you know,
like scar in the lion king,
right?
So there's always this shadowy figure in
the background that's malevolent and
psychopathic and power obsessed that's
attempting to take over the hierarchy
by,
by ill gotten means that and that that's
evil itself.
In some sense.
It's the archetype of evil.
And so that has to be taken into
consideration.
But the problem with the viewpoint
that's so prevalent in our society right
now is that nuts,
the patriarchal tyranny viewpoint is
that it's only the evil king.
And then that's particularly hard on
young men because if you believe that
all of our hierarchies are predicated on
nothing but arbitrary power,
and then that's a natural consequence of
masculinity.
Then whenever you see anyone whose
masculine manifest,
anything that's associated with
competence or confidence or,
or,
or um,
or let's say competitiveness or,
or you know,
heaven forbid,
aggression,
then you immediately assume that that's
nothing but a manifestation of
tyrannical power and that you discourage
it or,
or,
or you certainly failed to encourage it.
And I think that that's a dreadful
mistake because that,
that masculine energy,
whether that's characteristic of women
or men,
because women can certainly manifest
that,
that's something that should be
integrated and celebrate it and the way
you do that,
that's partly why mechanisms like
competitive sports are so necessary,
is that you want to take kids,
let's say boys are more competitive and
aggressive boys just for this example.
You want to take them and you want to
socialize them intensely so that they
take that aggressive,
competitive impulse and they're capable
of manifesting it inside a social
structure like a game so that it's a
benefit to everyone and you can do that
and did it.
It's not a problem.
You know,
you teach an aggressive kid that it's
beneath his dignity to bully someone
weaker so you can attach that right to
the competitiveness.
It's like you're a loser.
You bully someone weaker than you,
you're a loser.
That's pathetic slide.
It speaks right to that competitive
drive to want to be a loser.
Martial arts are so critical.
I mean,
that's one of the major tenants of
martial arts.
You know,
this is a is a huge part of what's
taught in traditional martial arts
academies as there's a very clear way of
behaving and you're never supposed to do
anything remotely like bullied and
you're supposed to have your power.
Exactly.
And you're supposed to have extreme
reverence for the people who taught.
You know what I mean?
Your master,
you literally call them a master in all.
Almost all martial arts,
they're referred to somebody.
Well,
so that's another thing that's really,
that's really interesting about a
functional hierarchy is like because the
leftist critics look at a hierarchy and
they think every position is up looking
down.
Right?
But what you're saying,
what you're pointing out is knowing a
functional hierarchy,
there's plenty of respect going up.
Right?
So it's not only,
it's not just power,
it's like its power,
its,
its authority and subordination.
At the same time,
voluntary subordination,
because you should be,
you should be properly subordinate to
the people who are better at what you're
doing.
Yes.
And in a functional organization that
happens naturally.
And the other thing that happens too,
and the radical leftist never take this
into account as far as I'm concerned,
is that one of the things I've learned
about people who've run successful
organizations,
whether they're academic or business,
is that they really loved mentoring
young people.
It's a,
it's an intrinsic pleasure because you
know,
you think,
well,
it's for the evil capitalist,
it's,
it's winner take all and,
and,
and to hell with everyone else.
And that's an unbelievably cynical view
of human nature.
It only really applies to people who are
genuinely psychopathic and they're very
rare.
And so most of the people I know that
have been hyper successful are
absolutely thrilled if they can find a
young person and they don't care
generally speaking about sex or creed or
color or any of that crap.
They care about competence.
They want to find a competent young
person who's got a lot of possibility
and then open up all sorts of doors of
opportunity for them and to see how they
can help them develop.
And if they can do that with 20 or 30
people,
then like my graduate,
my graduate supervisor had his,
uh,
he,
he's getting old and he had his
retirement party about two years ago and
about 30 of the people that he trained
in to becoming scientists came to his
party and they talked nonstop about the
beneficial effect that,
that he had on their life,
you know,
he found lot of them were,
they were young and smart but didn't all
that properly oriented in the world.
And he picked them out and gave them
opportunities and he certainly did.
This for me,
has opened all sorts of doors for me.
And that was a huge source of pleasure
in his life.
I think maybe the primary source,
he had a family as well,
and obviously his family was of primary
importance,
but in his professional career,
it wasn't his name on papers in his,
you know,
his,
his name in the mark.
Hey,
it was all these young people whose
careers he could foster.
It's never ending source of
satisfaction.
Yeah.
I think that's a critical aspect of
being a successful person,
that you have to realize that a,
there's a great personal benefit and
helping other people and that you feel
this.
This is not just like something that
looks good on paper you when you can
show some young person who's coming up
the way you're 10 years ahead of them
and you can say,
these are the mistakes that I made.
I can help you get through this,
and then you see them flourish.
There's a great deal of personal
satisfaction infinitely.
There's got to be some sort of an
evolutionary benefit to this.
Well,
that's.
that's part of.
See,
that's the thing is we are evolved for
reciprocity really are.
We're not evolved for power,
right?
This is what so deeply wrong about the
damn postmodernists in the Marxist is
that isn't what human first of all.
Power is not the best strategy to attain
success.
It's simply not.
It doesn't even work for chimpanzees
because the more the brute chimps,
you know,
the ones that that rule purely as a
consequence of force,
as soon as they weaken to subordinates
that are reciprocally engaged so that
have a friendship,
tear them into pieces,
so I don't care how strong you are,
three guys that are like two thirds of
your strength,
they're going to take you out so,
so you're much better situated in,
in society and in your life if you,
if you're in an interactive network of
reciprocally beneficial relationships
that works in Games,
but it also works in life and to reduce
that and,
and if you're competent,
so there's,
there's the killer combination,
hyper competence and the capacity for
genuine reciprocity that makes you
unstoppable.
Why is there this lack of understanding
and appreciating this nuance in people
that oppose these ideas?
Like what is,
what's the willingness to be ignorant
about all the variabilities,
especially when you consider the bulk of
the research?
Well,
I think some of it's justification for
failure.
You know,
like if you're not doing very well,
then it's really easy to think that the
game is rigged.
It's also easy to be resentful about
people who seem to have more than you
have,
especially if you're not thinking about
it very clearly.
You know,
and that's another thing that I've been
trying to lecture to people about is
that you should be very careful about
assuming that someone else has more than
you do.
I mean one of the best predictors of
whether someone has money is how old
they are.
So old people are Richard than young
people.
Well obviously right?
Because they had their whole life to
accrue wealth.
So like,
well who's got it better?
You want to be rich and older,
young and poor,
you know,
I mean you can't buy youth with money so
it isn't obvious who's better off in a
situation like that.
It's in fact,
I think most people who are old enrich
would trade it for young and poor fairly
damn quickly.
Well that's why people really get angry
when they see young rich people.
I know that's just too much to bear a
young,
rich,
famous
rapper.
Like what's that fellow that the 17 year
old little pump about that
famous 17.
But you know,
the folks in high school 17,
the funny thing too though,
is that,
you know,
even with people who have that,
that sort of,
let's call it good fortune,
you know,
independent of their talent,
you don't have to scratch beneath the
surface very far,
even successful people's lives until you
find it pretty decent vein of tragedy,
you know?
And so it,
it,
that jealousy of,
of,
of the successful is also based on a
really unit dimensional view of exactly
what constitutes success.
You know,
you see the trappings,
whatever they might be,
let's say it's a yacht and more money
than you know,
what to do with and you assume,
well that's going to put that person at
the pinnacle of a satisfying life.
But there's no shortage of dreadfully
unhappy and addicted celebrities.
And it isn't obvious always that more
money is good for people.
You know?
I mean you say,
oh,
that's a problem I'd like to have.
It's like,
look,
fair enough.
I mean there are worse problems,
but celebrity and fame and fortune are
also not that easy to deal with.
And they come with their own pitfalls.
Plus,
there's lots of things they don't
protect you against,
you know,
people still get divorced and they still
get sick and they still die and their
parents still get Alzheimer's and all of
that,
like the,
the fundamental tragic elements of life
are still in place.
One of the interesting things about
people that are jealous of other people
that are extremely successful is that
you are missing one of the core lessons
of competition.
One of the core lessons of competition
is to be inspired by those who are more
successful and not to try to chip them
down and take away their accomplishments
because they don't make you feel good.
Yeah.
The people that are pis,
port competition are always the ones
that are trying to diminish the
accomplishments of those who are
extremely successful.
You see this in sports fans.
If you see a loser fat sports fan
talking about what a piece of Shit
Lebron James is because he dropped the
ball or I missed a shot,
this the extreme reaction that they
could have to someone who's
extraordinarily successful is almost
always in direct proportion to how much
of a failure they are in their own life,
and that's one of the reasons why in
contrast it looks so ridiculous.
Yeah,
well that's part of the danger.
I would say that's part of the danger of
the entire identity politics movement is
that you know,
is that that reasonable care for the
dispossessed,
which we already talked about,
is easily contaminated by hatred and
resentment for people are not only
successful,
but who are the most annoying person
who's successful is the person who
deserves it.
Not the person who doesn't deserve it
because you can write the person who
doesn't deserve it off the lottery
winner.
You can say,
Oh yeah,
well,
you know,
he just got lucky.
Yeah,
exactly.
But then you see the person who's broken
themselves in half and you know come out
of a really pathological background and
has been successful and you're like,
you're,
you're uselessly.
I'm wasting your life away.
That's the sort of person that you
really don't like because they cast you
in a very dim light.
So this is where competition is so
important because the person that has a
background and competition has been
involved in competition,
sees a person who's busted their ass and
and become something really
extraordinary and it's incredibly
inspirational and you look to those
people and you want to read their
biographies and you want to watch
documentaries on them because it
literally gives you fuel.
Whereas the person who shies away from
competition is afraid of their own
insecurities and failures and really has
never tested themselves.
Those are the ones that find these
people extremely distasteful because
when they put themselves in comparison
to these incredible people,
they they come up short.
I will.
Every ideal experiences,
every ideal is a judge.
Yes.
So what's,
what's the answer to that?
No ideals.
That's a stupid.
That's a stupid suggestion.
No,
it certainly doesn't because then it
leaves people without any meaning in
their life.
No,
so well,
I think it speaks to what you were
talking about earlier,
that we needed diversity,
that we needed adversity,
we need difficulty,
we need struggle.
You need,
you need a weight to carry,
and if you don't have any of this,
you do not get your character tested.
You do not advance in your own
perception of who you are in this world
and how you,
how you engage with all the other people
around you.
You don't call out what's best in you
and then you can't live without that.
You need that.
And so,
and the trick seems to be that voluntary
acceptance of the adversity.
See,
that's one of the things that I think is
core to the mythos of Christianity
because there's an idea that you should
pick up your cross and stumble up hill.
And that's really what that means is
that,
you know,
you set your,
you set your eyes on some high level
vision,
the city of God on the hill,
whatever that happens to be,
you know,
and then you take the burden,
whatever burden you're capable of
lifting,
which is obviously going to be a burden
of suffering at least to some degree.
And you carry that voluntarily.
That's the trick is that.
And then you say,
well,
you need a purpose in your life.
It's like,
well look,
there's a lot of problems around you in
the world.
You have some problems,
some problems even that bother you.
Right?
Personally,
they seem to call out to you those
problems.
Maybe those are your problems.
Those are the problems you should solve.
And those I think are the call to
adventure.
So like there's a problem.
It bugs me.
Okay,
do something about that is your problem.
There's a certain amount that you could
tolerate.
I mean,
I think it's like weight training.
There's a certain amount where it
becomes detrimental.
Where you've overtrained your body's
breaking down.
There's a certain amount of problems
that you have in your life that are
extremely beneficial because through
going through these problems,
sorting them out,
you,
you build your spirit,
you build your character and if you
don't accomplish anything and you never
encounter any problems,
you are this gelatinous soft,
atrophied soul and you don't have the
intestinal fortitude or the spirit or
the.
The human potential has not been
developed to the point where you can
overcome adversity.
The only way to overcome adversities,
to face it so
that that optimism that you were talking
about.
So I've really been interested in
neurophysiology of the.
Of the sense of meaning because
neurophysiology.
Yeah,
because of the meat,
meaning the feeling of meaning is an
instinct.
It's not a thought.
It's not a secondary consequence of
rational processes.
It's way deeper than that.
It's something that drives rationality
itself.
So now you were just very amongst
people.
Definitely,
but it varies in this way as far as I
can tell.
So that.
So imagine as you said that there's an
optimal load,
right?
You exceed that and to your detriment
and you see that in the weight room.
You pull a muscle,
you hurt your,
you'll hurt yourself.
You can injure yourself very badly,
right?
You can take yourself out for the count
button.
Then if you,
if you work too little while then there
is no gain in it.
You have to find that thin edge where
you're competent in what you're doing,
but you're pushing yourself.
That's going to be where meaning lies.
That's what meaning tells people.
It says you're on the edge where you're
competent and and out of undue danger,
but pushing yourself enough so that
you're continually developing.
That's the instinct of meaning and that
looks to me like it's a consequence of
the interaction between the right and
the left hemispheres and the
consequences of the interaction between
the negative emotion systems,
anxiety and pain that regulate you,
that protect you from harm and the
exploratory in place.
Systems that drive you forward.
You want the exploratory in place,
systems to drive you forward,
but then they're regulated by these
negative emotions so you don't hurt
yourself,
and if you get that optimally right,
then that's the maximal.
That's the point of maximal challenge
and that makes you really alert because
your positive emotion is functioning.
That's what's driving you forward.
This is worth doing and your negative
emotions are alert to saying,
yeah,
but be awake and be careful and you know
what that's like in the weight room.
If you're lifting something that's at
the edge of your ability and you've got
a spotter,
you want a push and you can barely do it
and you want to make sure that you're
not going to like pull your arm down and
rip the hell out of your muscle,
but you.
You're right on that edge and now it's
the place of maximal gain and that sense
of meaning.
That's what puts you on the border
between chaos and order,
right?
Because too much order means you're just
practicing what you already know and
then you then you stultify and stagnate
and too much chaos means you better look
out because you're going to hurt
yourself.
You're pushing yourself beyond your
limits.
You stay right on that edge.
That's where there's maximum meaning and
you're wired for that edges.
Push it to push it.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the things I recommend to young
people,
especially true for people in their
twenties,
is that you should push yourself beyond
your limits of tolerance in your
twenties to find out where it is,
how much can you work,
how disciplined can you become?
Like,
can you work 12 hours a day?
Can you work eight hours a day?
Can you work three hours a day like flat
out where's your limit and how much,
how much work can you do and how much
socialization you should find out.
Push yourself past and then back off to
to that point where it's optimally
sustainable.
That's what a lot of people do,
isn't it?
I mean,
they party too much when they're in
their twenties.
They make a lot of mistakes.
It's,
it's,
it's what they're doing and I would say
in sort of a haphazard way,
right?
Because there's that instinct to go out
there and do more,
but it's unregulated and it's not.
It's not as self conscious as it might
be.
It's good to know that there's,
it's good to think about that as a goal.
It's like you're trying to discover what
your limitations are when you're,
when you're in your twenties so that you
can hit that edge so that you can
sustain yourself across the decades.
And so yeah,
because you don't,
you don't want to.
You don't want to have too much fun,
too much fun takes you out.
You don't want to be the oldest guy at
the disco,
you know?
It's not,
it's not fun being the 40 year old at
the singles bar.
Precisely so you want to make sure that
what you're doing is age appropriate and
you want to push yourself in every
direction that you can,
but you shouldn't be doing that with an
aim in mind.
It's like you're trying to make yourself
into a better and more competent person
and so some discipline along with the
fund is a good idea,
so to take care of yourself and the
people around you.
That's one of the things I recommended
to people and I've had quite a few
people actually tell me that they've
done this.
Interestingly enough.
I said,
well,
one thing you could aim at if you had
any sense when you were young is to be
the most worth you could be the most
reliable person at your father's
funeral.
And so I think that's a good challenge.
And I had a bunch of people come up to
me in this last tour and tell me that
that's exactly what they did.
These were often young guys,
you know,
like before 20 said my dad died suddenly
or died after years,
illness and it was just taken me out and
no wonder,
you know,
he said,
they said,
I was listening to your lectures.
You said you want to be the most
reliable person at the funeral because
everyone else is grieving and what the
hell else are you going to do?
He said that's what they tried to do and
not gotten through it,
so now that's part of that.
Picking up that load as far as I'm
concerned,
you get a little self respect out of
that two and a real sense,
right?
Because you know you're this sort of sad
suffering creature that's capable of a
fair bit of malevolence,
but if you find out that you can carry a
heavy load and take care of yourself and
have a little leftover for some other
people,
then you can wake up at three in the
morning and think,
well man,
I could be worse
and this is not a political perspective.
This is a positive constructive way of
looking at how to navigate the world.
But when you break down the sort of
behavior types,
whether it's the people that generally
support socialism or socialist ideas or
their anti-competition versus people
that are pro pushing yourself.
They fall into these right wing,
left wing sort of paradigms and this
really weird way that especially there.
I think that's especially
true on the radical ends.
But I think you get that on the radical
right too.
Because you should have people who are,
who are collectivists in their
fundamental orientation,
you know,
and they're,
they're trying to take undue credit for
who their racial ancestors were or
there.
Okay.
What,
what I would say with the political
issue is that I think that you can build
decent,
responsible people who are on the
middle,
right of the spectrum and the middle
left,
you know,
because I think that you can have left
wing political beliefs that are
genuinely aimed at aid to the
dispossessed without being resentful of
the hierarchies and without
contaminating it with jealousy for the
successful.
It's hard,
right?
You have.
Because when I worked for the NDP when I
was a kid,
wouldn't.
That was the Socialist Party in Canada.
The leaders,
some of the leaders were people like
that,
like a lot of the low level party
functionary types.
They were the activist types that you
still see today.
And there are mostly resentful.
I didn't like them at all,
but some of the leaders were genuinely
genuine advocates for the working class,
you know,
and they,
they had their flaws obviously,
but,
but there,
they put their money where their mouth
was and they were trying to ensure that
the hierarchies we're open to
advancement for,
for,
for let's say,
the common person,
so to speak,
the person who stopped up at the bottom
or for their children,
which might even be more important,
you know,
so that the hierarchy's remain open to
genuine competency based on competence,
which would be a perfectly reasonable
thing for the left.
Who insist on right is that,
let's bloody well make sure that it's a
fair game and so that people don't get
locked out of movement forward because
of arbitrary positions of power.
And that's,
that's,
that's a reasonable,
that's a reasonable part of the
discussion.
So I think if you build better people,
you can build better people on the left
and on the right and people that be
good.
I appreciate that rules to the game or
better for everyone.
They're better for the people that when
they're better for the people that are
coming up,
they're better for us if that's a real
structure in real rules and that you're
better off being a guy like Wayne
Gretzky.
Yes,
better off being a guy who's respected,
uh,
plays the game correctly and just does
his best and really,
truly become the champion and loved by
all because of it.
You're better off in every way.
Right?
And that's the most state.
The other thing that's so cool about
that.
So imagine this,
this is the antidote tomorrow.
Relativism.
Okay.
So the first thing is,
is that there are real problems and,
and hierarchical organizations can offer
real solutions socially and personally,
so you can confront the problems
courageously and you can solve.
So that's real and ameliorate suffering
and limits malevolence.
And so there's nothing morally relative
about that.
The second is that sense of meaning that
we discussed.
That's not some philosophical second
order consequences of thinking.
It's way deeper than that.
That sense of meaning tells you when
you're the God ski.
The Russian psychologist called that the
zone of proximal development,
which I believe is where the phrase the
zone came from and so in the zone of
proximal development,
this is what adults do
with children,
little kids that are learning to talk.
Adults automatically talk to little
children who are learning to talk at a
level that slightly exceeds their
current vocabulary.
They do that without even knowing it and
that puts those kids in the zone,
right?
Because if you just talk baby,
talk to kids,
then all they learned is baby talk and
if you just talk like an adult and they
don't understand a word you're saying,
so you'll find this happy medium in
between where the kid mostly understands
what you're talking about and that
you're pulling them forward so that puts
them in the zone.
Now it's a meaningful zone and so you
can feel the operation of that zone in
your own life.
That's what the Taoists are on a boat
because they say,
well,
the Dow is the way.
Right?
And that's the pathway between chaos and
order.
That's meaning and you can feel that in
your life when you're deeply engaged in
something like we have deeply engaged in
conversations,
okay,
which is part of the reason that we keep
having them and I think why they're
popular and we're not paying attention
to how the clock is ticking or how time
is flowing or even to the fact that
we're doing what we're doing.
We're just having a conversation and
it's meaningful.
It's engaged,
it keeps our eyes focused and our
senses.
I'm concentrated on what's happening and
the reason for that is that there's
enough information flowing between us so
that we're being slightly transformed as
a consequence of the discussion.
Right?
So we're both comfortable.
We trust each other.
We trust that the conversation is aimed
at something that's a mutual benefit.
We trust each other to tell the truth to
the to the degree that we're capable of
doing that.
And then when you engage in this
exchange of information and to the
degree that it's breaking you down a
little bit and building you up in a
different way,
that's a little death and rebirth.
There's constant little deaths and
rebirths in a meaningful conversation.
Then that keeps you alive and
functioning and that that focus is like
that that speaks to you so deeply that
that focus happens without any
consciousness and that's meaning and
that's that line between chaos and order
and that's real.
That has nothing.
It's,
it's,
and I would say,
here's another thing that's cool,
so that line between chaos and order,
that's the same thing that's happening
when you're playing a game property,
right?
Because you're in the game and you're.
You're exercising your skill,
but you're pushing it,
but you're pushing it in a way that's
also a benefit to your teammates and to
the progression of the game as such and
to being a better general player.
You're doing all that at the same time
and you're evolved with enough natural
intelligence so that the sum,
total output of your nervous system says
to you,
you're in the right place at the right
time doing the right thing,
and that's what makes your life
meaningful,
and that's real.
I then I think it's more real than
anything else.
I think it's more real than suffering.
I think it's more real than malevolence
because it's the antidote to both of
those and so the whole moral,
moral relativism issue for me is a
nonstarter.
It's just wrong.
There's lots of ways of interpreting the
world,
but there aren't very many ways of
interpreting it optimally and you can
feel when you're doing that,
it makes you stronger.
And then people that come to me
after my talks and say,
well,
you know,
I'd be putting my life together.
I've developed a vision.
I've been trying to be more responsible.
I've been trying to be more honest and
put my relationships together.
They're all sparkly eyes because of this
or crying sometimes because it's really
had an impact on them at a deep level.
They think,
Oh wow,
this actually works.
It's like,
yeah,
it actually works.
It's real.
And I would say as well that that's
associated with the idea of the deep
western idea of the logos,
which is meaning in action and speech.
So you know,
if we have a conversation that's
meaningful,
then that's a manifestation of the
spirit of the logos and that's the thing
that destroys.
And,
and,
and recreates at the same time because
you learn something,
destroy something,
destroys a little presupposition that
you had that was erroneous and replaces
it with something that's healthier and
every time you have a meaningful
conversation that happens.
It's like a little tweak now.
It wasn't quite right here.
Kick that moves and something new takes
its place.
So in,
that's a little death and rebirth
instead of the catastrophic death and
rebirth that you might have to have if
you weren't paying attention.
So that's all tied together.
It's all tied together with that
phenomenon of meaning.
And that's the same as the adoption of
responsibility.
That all ties together so nicely.
The other concept of meaning,
like what is important,
that it's so,
it's so huge to people but so fleeting.
It's so difficult to like what is
meaning?
Well,
you know,
there's a simple one,
so I like family and loved ones and
companionship and community and finding
something that you enjoy doing that you
can do that.
It seems bigger than you or bigger than
yourself but,
but meaning like the meaning of life,
what is meaning?
And it's one of the things that gives
people so much existential anxiety and I
think is the cause of a lot of despair.
Because while you can question it,
yes,
but the thing is is that that's one of
the dangers of rationality is that see
the Egyptians associated,
the Catholics did this to some degree
too.
They associated rationality,
rationality with a proclivity to
malevolence,
partly because rationality tends to fall
in love with its own productions.
Intelligence has this like inbuilt
arrogance and the Egyptians in
particular were really insightful.
They tried to replace the idea of
intelligence as the highest virtue with
the idea of attention as the highest
virtue because something Elvis Huxley
knew,
he wrote a book called Island Island was
an island that was populated by head.
A lot of birds on it and the birds could
talk and all they did was say,
pay attention to remind everybody on the
island to pay attention all the time.
But you,
you can undermine your sense of meaning
and you can question it.
But the best thing to do is to actually
pay attention to when it manifests
itself.
Because it's a.
it's a phenomenon like like color or
like or like love or like beauty,
it,
it exists.
It isn't something you created,
something that you discover and you can
discover it.
You just have to watch it like you're
ignorant about yourself.
You think,
okay,
well I'm gonna I,
I,
I've taught,
told
my clinical clients to do this,
and my students was,
watch yourself for two weeks.
Just watch,
like you don't know who you are and
notice when you're doing something that
you're engaged in,
so like you'll see it.
Maybe it's only 10 minutes because your
life is pretty out of balance,
but you'll see that whole man,
I was engaged in something there for 10
minutes.
It's like,
why?
What was,
what did you do that was right that
engaged you?
You were in the right place at the right
time,
doing the right thing for a few minutes.
What was it?
What were the preconditions?
There's this line in the new testament.
Christ says,
the Kingdom of God is spread across the
earth,
but men do not see it and that's what it
refers to is that you.
You Wander into paradise now and then
when you're engaged,
when you're deeply engaged in something
but you don't notice it,
you don't think,
oh look,
I'm in the right place and everything's
working out right now.
It means I've got it right somehow and
then I need to practice being there more
and more and more,
which is while that's the appropriate
thing to try to practice and that's to
make that,
to come to some negotiated,
what would you call it?
It's it.
It's to come to a negotiation with that
intrinsic sense of meaning and to
realize it as a fact rather than just as
an opinion or or something that's
secondary because it's annoying
concept for people though would be so
aware of who they are and what they're
doing.
They could recreate that so when they do
feel that feeling of meaning that they
could figure out a way to get back into
that state and what were all the
extenuating circumstances and where,
where's my head at?
What caused me to have this,
this feeling like things were right?
Yes.
Well,
it's like someone gives you a gift and
you think,
well,
I'd like that gift again.
It's like,
yeah,
well you have to figure out what it was
that you did to deserve it,
so to speak,
and yeah,
no,
it requires a fair bit of.
It requires a fair bit of careful
reflection,
but it also requires that ignorance is
you have to think,
well,
I don't know who I am.
I'm going to find some things
meaningful.
What are they?
They might not even be things you want
to find meaningful.
They might be things that you might even
be ashamed of,
you know,
because sometimes people are interested
in things that they don't think that
they should be interested in.
Like maybe you'll,
you'll,
you'll have a guy who was,
who was kind of a cliche,
but who was,
you know,
socialized to be real tough guy and he
finds out that he's kind of interested
in art or aesthetics.
It's like,
well,
he's shamed that because maybe it's too
feminine or whatever.
Well,
it's doesn't matter because that's
actually speaking that that's actually
something that's speaking to him from
the core of his genuine being.
He's gonna have to pursue that,
or you might find that someone who's
really agreeable and kind of a pushover
stands up to someone just once at work
says what they really think and then
they realized afterwards,
wow,
you know,
that was exactly right,
and they think,
oh my God,
you know,
I've decided when I was a little kid,
maybe they had a harsh father and they
decided when they were four,
I've never going to be angry in my whole
life.
There's something wrong with aggression,
so they've gone out of their way their
whole life to be free of conflict.
Then they find out the one day they
stand up for themselves that that whole
that they'd parsed off as inappropriate
is actually contains exactly what they
need to put themselves together.
Or do you find what you need where you
least want to look?
That's the old chemical dictum in sterk,
wiliness infinite tour.
Right?
I want to talk to you about activists
because it's something that you brought
up earlier saying that you,
you know,
you find them appealing.
I want to know what you think the
motivation of a lot of these
particularly radical left wing activists
that want to shut down lectures and
screen people down in these auditoriums.
What do you think the motivation of
these people is and what do you.
What do you think is the root of it?
Well,
I think that it's a quick route to moral
virtue.
You know,
like it's actually really hard to put
yourself together and you have to do
that in ways that you can't trump it,
you know,
because most of the things that are
wrong with you are kind of low.
What would you call it?
Second rate and embarrassing your all,
your stupid little habits and your
proclivity to procrastinate and all the
things that you're minorly ashamed of
and then you have to work on those
slowly because the probability that
you're going to be able to fix them
quickly is low and you can't really brag
about it because it's so embarrassing
just to admit that they exist to begin
with it.
You can hardly brag about it and it sort
of painstaking private work and you
don't get a lot of social,
you don't get a lot of quick social
status for it.
It's effortful,
embarrassing,
humbling and difficult,
and then you can do something like be an
activist and you get all that public
acclaim for being on the good side with
no effort whatsoever.
And so it's a loss.
Do you think that
any motivation at all to try to make the
world a better place?
Yes,
I think that's part of it.
Sure.
Well,
I think it's flavored by this desire to
broadcast your virtue.
Yes.
Because it's very difficult to make the
world a better place.
You know?
That's the thing is no,
I mean young people have a messianic
impulse.
That's another thing that was documented
by piaget that there's a stage,
you know,
in late adolescence where you want to
make the world a better place.
I would say that's probably part of the
impulse to,
you know,
establish a permanent relationship and
have a family and take care of people,
you know,
and to take on some of the burden of
life.
It's the psychological precursor to that
and it's reasonable for smart young
people to be concerned about broader
philosophical issues if they tilt in
that direction as well.
But it's all too easy for that to be
pathologized into resentment for,
for those who seem to have more unfairly
and also to take the easy route out and
there aren't easy routes.
There are only difficult routes to doing
useful things and it's better just to
do that.
And then.
So I think that there's some impulse to,
you know,
there's some wish that things could be
less unfair and that fewer people could
suffer,
but it's kind of a low level virtue
that,
that reflects of compassion.
You know,
I,
I'm not saying it's,
it's without merit because it's the,
that compassion is the basis for the
ability to take care of,
of people who are ill and and infants
and so forth.
This low level like where's that?
It's not thought through.
Things are complicated.
It's hard to.
It's hard to make complicated systems
work better and it's really easy to make
them work worse.
What about activists that want to shut
down certain speakers?
Like someone who's,
in my opinion,
a fairly innocuous in terms of the net.
Here's one,
Christina Hoff summers.
I just don't see a good argument for
shutting her down.
She's so polite.
She's a feminist.
She's well read.
She's a really nice person and Janice is
like that too.
In the Canada.
It sort of person doesn't make sense
that people would shout her down.
Yet they do say horrible things about
her.
They mischaracterize her in a really
brutal way that it completely
invalidates their argument or their
opposition to her,
to anyone is paying attention to what
she said.
Oh,
well,
a lot.
A lot of it is.
A lot of it is also just immature acting
out.
Yes.
There's an arrogance tolerated and I
very strange way it is.
It is.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
it's part of our doubt,
I suppose about authority on a boat.
It's and our willingness to assume that
all authority is contaminated by power.
It's like it's shunned.
Heckling too.
It's almost like you have,
you're doing a play or a musical or
you're singing a song and someone just
decided to start screaming out,
well that person's an asshole.
But if you're espousing and opinion,
Yep,
and that person decides to scream out
and they,
they do.
So under the guise of moral virtue on
tolerated,
undeserved access to power.
Yes.
You know,
and it's no wonder that radical leftists
in particular concentrate on power.
Everything's about power.
Well then it's okay if they use power as
part of their means of expression.
It's like,
well,
you're just playing power games.
It's perfectly reasonable even
appropriate for me to play power games
because you know,
I'm oppressed compared to you.
If everything's power,
then everybody gets to yell and there's
no.
One of the things I realized about about
recently as well is that there isn't a
debate about free speech.
Exactly not the way that we think about
it,
you know,
because there's the classical defense of
free speech,
so the classical defense of free
speeches that it's better for both of us
if we're able to exchange our opinions
because I have the opportunity to learn
from you and you have the opportunity to
learn from me and you have the
opportunity to learn from your own
mistakes and social feedback and so do
I and negotiation beats war.
Okay,
so that's kind of the classical now,
but that's predicated on some
assumptions and those are.
You're an autonomous being.
You're capable of formulating an opinion
that that's actually unique to you and
that in dialogue we can mutually modify
each other's unique opinions in a way
that produces a mutually harmonious and
beneficial outcome.
That's all the predicate.
Well,
the people who are opposed to free
speech,
you see,
it's not that they're trying to shut
down people whose opinions are different
than theirs.
Exactly.
It's that they're opposed to the idea
that free speech exists.
It's a way deeper problem because at the
bottom of the postmodernist mess is the
following assumption is that,
well,
there's no.
There's no one way of interacting with
the world that's preferable to any other
way and so what people do is organize
themselves into hierarchies of power and
then struggle for dominance within the
hierarchies and then the hierarchy
struggled between each other.
So it's a landscape of worrying
hierarchies.
That's all it is and you think that
you're a person and that you have an
opinion but you're not.
You're just the mouthpiece of your
privileged hierarchy and so am I and so
and it's incommensurate.
If we're from different hierarchies,
there isn't a you talking to me that
could come to an agreement.
There's just you acting as a mouthpiece
for your power and me acting as a
mouthpiece for my power and so since I'm
part of my group and I want to win
because it's all about power,
then why the hell would I ever want you
to talk?
It's not like I have anything to learn
from you or even that learning is
possible,
or even that there are two people having
a discussion.
There's nothing but the mouthpiece of
power.
There's two mouthpieces of power warring
and so why should I listen to you?
I'll just shut you down because then I
went,
so this,
this free speech debate isn't about
whose,
whose opinion should be allowed within
an overarching framework where free
speeches is a real thing.
It's a debate about whether there such a
thing as free speech at all.
The radical postmodernist types.
They denied even that.
There's such a thing as an autonomous
individual in any way.
You're just.
You're just the nexus of economic
forces,
economic and social forces.
You're entirely socially constructed.
There's no you.
These are deep criticisms like I've.
I've made this case before that the
postmodern types,
although they have to ally themselves
with the Marxist for for reasons that we
don't have to go into,
they are going after things that are so
fundamental.
You can't believe it.
They don't.
There is no autonomous individual in the
postmodern world.
That's,
that's a modern Western enlightenment
viewpoint.
That's or a Christian viewpoint or a
Judeo Christian viewpoint or maybe an
abrahamic religion viewpoint.
Who the hell knows it might be that that
deep.
You're the nexus of sociological forces.
There's no integrated self.
You don't have ideas or opinions and
there's no dialogue between us that
doesn't exist.
There's your group,
your identity,
your struggle for power,
and that's all this is.
Your interpretation of this is.
This is the fundamental essence of
postmodernism.
Especially.
It's especially true in the format
espoused by Derrida and foucault for Co.
Everything's about power.
Everything is about power,
and dara dara was definitely.
That's why he criticized the idea of
logo centrism.
Logos is that ability of the individual
to engage in dialogue.
Route for dialogue is logos or logic.
That's all criticized.
That's all gone.
The identity politics players,
the serious,
the people who are serious about this
philosophically,
they don't believe in the idea of the
autonomous individual that's gone,
so it's not like they're playing a game
within,
you know,
you think,
well,
this is a game.
WE're all playing a game where we agree
on some things and we're just
disagreeing about the details.
It's like,
oh no,
no,
you don't want to make that mistake.
This critique is way,
way deeper than that,
which is why derrida was opposed to the
idea of logo centrism.
He didn't believe in the idea of an
autonomous individual that didn't exist.
That's just a fiction set up by those
who have used the idea of the autonomous
individual to advance their power
maneuvering within the confines of the
colonialist.
The colonialists west.
No,
and what's the rationalization for that
perspective?
Is this to enhance their argument to try
to,
to push forth their ideas in less,
less debatable way.
Like what?
I think the motivation is hatred for
competence,
hatred for competence.
I truly believe that I've been trying to
do down like go down as deep as I could
to find out why the layers of the.
I think it's cain and abel.
Wow.
I really believe that.
I think that because I can't understand
the motivation.
Otherwise it's like,
well,
why are you tearing these things down
while it's on the base?
You know,
we have sympathy for the oppressed.
It's like,
well,
well why?
Like wearing,
you're wearing your conceptualization.
does that iDea of sympathy for the
oppressed come from.
You don't even have the iDea of the
individual in your conceptualization.
It's like that's just a.
I don't,
I don't.
I don't buy any of that.
I think it's cain and abel row all the
way down.
Do you think that when you're talking
about the scandinavian model where
they've made it incredibly equal and
through this massive effort to take away
any opportunity or to to to rather open
up every possible opportunity for women
that men also have and you've seen
these,
these differences in genders actually
accentuate because of this.
Do you Think that maybe what we're
seeing also,
even in terms of the postmodernists and
the radical leftist versus people in the
right,
this same sort of competition aspect of
it is also problematic because it's one
of the reasons why there's so much
debate in the first place and that if
we.
If we had maybe more middle ground and
more opportunity,
there would be less of an argument.
There would be less of a reason to have
these,
these extreme polar opposites that may
be embracing of more like there's
certain socialist aspects of our society
that we just accept.
Right?
Like the fire department,
right?
Yeah,
like universal provision of
infrastructure.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
It's schools should be,
I think more emphasized in that
direction,
but it it gears towards privatized
schools for people with higher incomes
which gets away more from socialism and
sort of reinforces capitalist more.
Right,
but I think things like maybe perhaps
even universal basic income or certainly
universal health care with you,
what you guys have in Canada,
which we don't have here,
and definitely a higher education making
higher education,
far more accessible and far less costly.
Stop subsidizing these student Loans.
Stop making student loan.
something that you can never ask.
Well,
I think this is part of the eternal
debate,
right?
Because we've already talked about the
utility of hierarchies and the necessity
of putting those who can in charge,
but the consequence of that,
which is an unequal distribution of both
talent and resources.
Well,
you don't want that to get so steep that
people stack up at the bottom because
you're all society starts to destabilize
and so you have to have a continual
discussion between the left and the
right to see how you stop the bottom
from suffering.
Yeah,
from hitting zero because zero is not
good.
You can't play when you hit zero and
that's not good,
and so I don't think there is a
universal solution to that problem
because the problem keeps manifesting
itself.
Think about a death and eternal problem
here.
Here's the problem.
There's a set of problems that'll never
go away.
Now what the problems are change,
but the fact that there are problems
never go away.
Okay?
The fact that you have to produce
hierarchies to solve those problems
never goes away.
The fact that the hierarchy's dispossess
never goes away,
but the detail shift all the time and so
the whole reason that you need the
political discussion is to take a look
at the particulars of the hierarchies
and the particulars of the dispossession
and say,
okay,
well now we need to shim it up here and
now we need to shim it up here and now
we need to adjust this and now we need
to adjust this because you can't come up
with a final solution to those problems.
I think that's partly why you have
consciousness itself,
you know,
because if you could automate the
solution,
imagine there was a permanent,
well there's a permanent solution to
breathing.
You have a paRt of your brain that just
breathes.
You don't think about it.
You don't adjust it while you do a bit
when you're talking,
but you get my point.
It's like problem taken care of.
Well,
there's other problems that are so
fluid,
like they're eternal problems,
but they're so fluid in their detail
that you need awareness and linguistic
capacity to address them.
And I would say the problem of hierarchy
and dispossession fit exactly into that
category is that we're going to organize
ourselves hierarchically because talent
is unequally distributed.
It doesn't matter.
Like as soon as you invent basketball
and instantly you know there's one
percent of the population who are super
great at basketball.
it doesn't matter.
As soon as you set up an arbitrary value
structure,
you get hierarchy,
then there's the whole schlubs at the
bottom that can put a ball in the hoop
to save their lives.
And,
and That's an eternal problem.
That's why it says in the new testament
that the poor will be with us always a
very pessimistic if there's two lines
like that.
One is to those who have everything more
will be given.
And from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.
That's a rough line.
And the second is the poor will be with
us always.
Okay?
So why?
Well,
it's a reflection of what we just
described is that you're going to get
hierarchical structures in.
They're going to dispossess okay?
So then what we want to do is we want to
use mercy.
Say justice gives you what you deserve,
so that's on the competitive end.
You get what you deserve,
but there's this old idea in old
religious idea.
This is a good idea.
God rules with two hands,
right hand is justice in the left hand
is mercy.
Justice means you get what you deserve,
but the world can't survive that way
because people are flawed and make
mistakes.
And if you only got exactly what you
deserved,
it would be a hell of a world,
right?
Because you'd be punished for every
single mistake you make.
You know,
you be held accountable in a way that
would be unbearable.
So that has to be tempered with mercy
and and so maybe the left is the is the
end of the distribution that tempers
with mercy when,
when it's functioning properly,
but it can degenerate into that came
like resentment of the,
of the successful.
And that's a danger on the right you
have the opposite danger which is well,
you know,
you advance because of your competence,
but then that can also fly.
And so you want to hang onto that,
that position,
even though your know your competence no
longer justifies it,
you start to use the advantages of your
position to accrue benefits for yourself
that you did not earn,
and that's the proclivity of the,
of the hierarchy to become blind and
tyrannical.
And that's a.
That's an eternal problem.
The,
the,
the egyptians had a garden for that.
Oh,
cyrus.
cyrus was the god of hierarchies and he
was always threatened by seth,
who is evil brother in his evil brother
was always conspiring to overcome him.
And that's the problem with hierarchies
is that they tilt towards tyranny and
the reasonable says that watch
the hierarchies because they tilt
towards tyranny.
It's like,
yes,
it's true,
but that doesn't mean that the idea of
hierarchy itself is flawed.
And that doesn't mean that all
hierarchies are tyrannical.
That's going way too far.
Do you think that the scandinavian model
that has revealed that when you do make
things more equal,
you will find that people generally tend
to gravitate more towards traditional
gender roles that does this.
Do you think that this makes people
happier?
Has it been observed that this is a
happier results?
That's a good question.
The indices of life satisfaction are
pretty high in scandinavia,
but I don't know if anybody has done an
analysis that would indicate whether
the,
the sexual sorting is a contributor to
that.
Oh,
that's a good question.
I mean the general idea has been that
the scandinavians are happier because
their societies are more egalitarian,
but,
but they're not more egalitarian in the
sense that men and women are also more
different.
So men and women are more different,
but the opportunities are more
egalitarian.
Yeah.
So,
but so then,
but then the societies are more,
are more satisfied,
but it's tough because there's other
variables because the scandinavian
countries are relatively homogenous,
right.
And more homogenous societies tend to be
more peaceful and happier,
not,
not more diverse societies.
And they're also small countries,
so they're somewhat easier to govern and
they tend to be wealthy.
So those.
So it'd be hard to parse out all those
contributors,
right.
To figure out what it is that's making
the scandinavians relatively content.
This is almost like a super tribe versus
a country.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Well and those,
those sorts of societies in some sense
are easier to manage so there are
benefit to this,
this model that we could perhaps bring
to the United States or to Canada and
maybe mitigate some of the issues that
we have between the right and the left.
Like maybe there's some sort of a
compromise that will lead to a less less
debate and dispute.
Well,
I think that you guys in the states are
doing real well actually.
Personally.
I mean,
you know,
your,
your system of checks and balances seems
to work out pretty well.
There's a fair bit of,
let's say left domination right now of,
of the mainstream media.
I think that's a reasonable claim and
also of academia and have the
intelligentsia,
but the political system is skewed
pretty hard to the republican end of
things at the moment.
And so that's not a bad balance.
And then in the last election,
I mean maybe you could make a case
perhaps that things had tilted a little
too far to the republican side,
but that,
that got balanced out because the
democrats took the house again and it
seems like they were more moderate
democrats.
That seems to be the scuttlebutt.
So you know,
it isn't obvious to me that your system
isn't functioning well.
I think that one of the things that's
happening that's making things look more
contentious than they are is that the
mainstream media is under such assault
by the up and coming media forms
colluding.
People like you,
that as their financial models
deteriorate and as their journalistic
standards take a hit,
and as they lose their fact checkers and
their time to be careful with the
stories,
they concentrate more on exaggerating
the extremes to attract attention.
And so,
you know,
there was an article published in the
atlantic monthly about a month ago
showing that didn't.
It depends on how you calculate these
things,
but that the radical leftists and the
radical right wingers are only about
five percent of the population on each
side and that most the vast majority of
americans consider themselves something
approximating the relatively silent
majority,
and so I don't think that things are
polarized,
is as badly as they seem and it is also
the case right now that if you poll
people and ask them about the conditions
of their life in the United States,
they tend to say that they're doing
quite well,
but that other people aren't.
And so I Think maybe,
I don't know this for sure,
but,
but I think maybe that the technological
pressure that's being put on the
mainstream media is driving extreme
political views as a means of gathering
the attention of a shrinking market
share.
That's,
that's a very interesting take on it.
I wonder how detrimental that is to us
as a whole because we are constantly
dealing with this click bait you
nonsense headline,
you know,
in every,
every,
everything is a dispute.
Everything's a war.
Everything was nerve wracking.
Yes.
You know,
I mean I noticed this years ago because
I really stopped watching the news or 25
years ago,
although I've been heavily involved in
the last two years because I noticed
that most of what passed for news wasn't
because my sense was,
well,
if it isn't important in a month,
if it is an important month from now,
it was never important and almost
everything that's news is important
right now,
and so I tried to stay away from that.
It was better for my peace of mind and I
often recommended to my clinical clients
who were depressed and anxious that they
shield themselves from the news as much
as possible,
but now there's the news is everywhere,
right?
It's everywhere.
It's twitter,
it's facebook,
it's youtube.
It's like we're just inundated by it.
It's like cnn on steroids.
It's 24 hour news cycle and it's
produced by everyone whether they're
informed or not and it's really high
emotion and I think that that is making
things look a lot worse to us than they
actually are.
I think it's also similar to what we
were talking about earlier when it comes
to reading comments on instagram or
twitter.
I just think there's just an amount of
data.
Yep.
That's incomprehensible.
I don't think you can handle it.
I don't think you would navigate it.
You can't navigate that many
relationships.
I mean,
the reason why we have this dunbar's
number in our head,
we,
if you're dealing with hundreds of
thousands of people,
in your case,
a million followers that are constantly
interacting with you,
it's going to fucking drive you mad.
Well,
you don't even know what to do with it
because I.
Well,
I don't even know what my ethical
obligation is to my twitter followers,
you know,
because like there's a million people
following.
Can't react to all of them.
Definitely.
Well,
certainly I know one limitation which is
that having it drive me insane is
probably not a good outcome for anyone
except for those who hope that I would
fall back.
Say this is a personal thing,
right?
Because they're responding and the
mentions are to you personally,
but in a lesser way perhaps,
but still also overwhelming is just the
sheer amount of information that's
available constantly about everything.
There's,
there's a million stories every day
about every single thing that's going on
in your life,
well,
everywhere,
everywhere on the planet and how are you
supposed to navigate that?
How are you supposed to get through life
and concentrate on things that are truly
meaningful for you in the present moment
without being completely detached from
the outside world.
It's this balance that people try to
find that is so elusive.
It's so hard to figure out how much to
watch.
How much of this political process do I
pay attention to?
Well,
that's the big technological challenge.
yes.
You know,
I mean,
we thought when I was a kid we thought,
oh my god,
you know,
kids are sitting in front of the
television four hours a night.
It's like,
well,
you ain't seen nothing yet.
No.
All day long.
No kidding.
Phones all day long.
Yeah,
and the phones are so much more powerful
than television that there.
Well,
it's like a typewriter compared to a
computer.
Yes.
You know,
and yeah,
it's,
well it's,
it's so,
so we don't know how to adjust to that
psychologically,
but it's even worse than that because as
soon as you adjust to the degree that
you do,
the technology changes on you.
Right.
So it was more immersive and it's always
leading in that direction.
So it's a real mean.
You know,
I see this especially with parents who
have teenage kids.
It's like they know the phones aren't,
you know,
I've been talking to some teenagers
lately about,
about,
you know,
maybe these are kids that are getting
bullied on social media.
It's like think,
well when I was 14,
you know,
it's kind of a rough time of life and
you go to school and you've got your
friends and you've got your enemies and
then you come home and your friends
aren't there and neither are your
enemies.
Right.
You're,
you're outside.
There's an outside of that.
But now in social media there's no
outside.
You know,
one kid I was talking to had moved
schools and he's doing quite well in the
new one,
but the people from the person's old
school are still after them on social
media,
so you know,
and you think,
well just don't use your phone.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
You tell that to your teenager.
You try not using your phone for a whole
day.
You think,
well,
the teenager is going to be able to
manage the phone.
It's like,
no,
they're not.
You can't manage the phone.
Nobody can manage the flow.
It's not just teenagers.
My middle daughter is 10 years old and
all of our friends have phones.
All of.
There's like two of her friends that
don't have phones and they come over the
house and we have a rule at our house.
You can't use a phone like once you get
inside the house,
there's no phones.
You have friends come over the house.
They want to constantly be on their
phone and we said like,
you can't do that.
And they look you like,
what are you talking about?
This is my life.
My life is my phone.
They want to make twitter posts and
instagram and they want to do facebook
and they want,
they want to snap chat with each other,
with bunny ears on and that these kids
are just doing this all day long and
they are mastering the technology.
That's the other thing.
It's not surprising that they're trying
to adapt to it,
but.
But it's happening at a really early age
because if you're giving your kid a
phone,
you're not putting any parental filters
on it.
You're allowing that kid to have full
access to google and the worldwide web
and they're just going to.
If you give your kid to phone and you
don't think they'll know how to use the
phone better than you within a year,
you're a fool.
It's true.
No,
they're going to.
They're going to have that thing figured
out in ways that you haven't even
imagined,
so you're not controlling it.
That's for sure.
It's a.
It is a very extraordinarily
unprecedented time to sort of navigate
this world and I don't think any does
not have been.
I mean,
civilizations have a deal with worse
things,
right?
In terms of violence and famine and
disease,
but I don't think anyone's had to deal
with such a,
like a radically transformative medium.
Like this range of possibilities.
well,
and you ain't seen nothing yet,
right?
I mean this is just getting going.
Well.
Have you been watching the boston
dynamics videos?
Oh my god.
Those guys in here.
Oh yeah.
I bet.
I mean the amount of progress they've
made in five years is just absolutely
staggered,
but they smell like sulfur and they
don't even know.
I bet you bringing me in here.
Go on.
These guys are doing well.
Elon musk was on the podcast talking
about some new development there,
work on called neuro link and that this
is some radical new way of accentuating
bandwidth between human beings and
information and just increasing the
access to it.
And he was very vague about it.
He said it was going to come out within,
you know,
x amount of months.
Yeah.
Well they've already,
you know,
there are scientists who've already
managed direct brain to computer links.
Right?
So you can get monkeys,
for example,
to move a robotic arm.
And so,
and I suspect that,
you knoW,
you're,
you can,
you can learn to control single neurons
in your face.
My suspicions are that we'll be able to
develop technologies that'll be
wearable,
that won't have to be neural implants,
that you'll be able to communicate with
neurally.
And if that's not very far down the road
and the,
uh,
you know,
the probability that we're going to
build,
you know,
you know about,
uh,
what's his name,
kurtzweil his idea of the singularity
and well,
that's a wild idea and it seems somewhat
improbable.
And I had a friend who once told me that
if something's impossible then it won't
happen.
There'll be something that will come up
to stop it that you won't expect.
And maybe the singularity is one of
those things.
But,
you know,
I know a lot of guys who were in the
high end co computational world and a
lot of them are convinced that we're
within a decade of a machine.
This is powerful as a human brain.
And I know people have been saying that
for a long time,
but jesus,
you know,
computers are getting good at emotion
recognition.
They're getting really good at facial
They can communicate with one another,
they can imitate those boston dynamic
robots are pretty damn impressive and
they're mostly autonomous.
we've got all sorts of things that can
navigate on their own,
like these autonomous cars,
like all these things are.
They're coming together real fast.
Have you ever watched black mirror on
netflix?
The only one I watched was the one that
outlined what the chinese are now doing
to their own people.
Oh yeah.
The crisper.
No,
no.
The one where everything you do is rated
right?
The social network one,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Switch,
which is quite frightening and
reasonably probable 100 percent
probable.
I was talking about the one,
I think it's called heavy metal.
It's about autonomous robots that seek
out people and kill them and these
artificial intelligence people that are
making these boston dynamic robots and
you know,
the.
The scariest one that I read about was a
darpa one called the eater robot,
ea t r.
It operates on.
It uses as a fuel.
It uses biological material as fuel,
which means if you're kidding,
no kidding.
No,
I'm not kidding.
jesus see a car,
so this is going to be able to eat dead
bodies in the field theoretically and
use it as fuel to kill.
good.
Oh good.
That sounds like a fine thing to
develop.
Fucking imagine an army of robotic armed
artificially intelligent things.
Corp cedars,
eat corpses in order to have fuel to
continue to kill someone's.
Obviously imagining that it's made and
this is a real thing.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
part of the reason that I'm doing what
I'm doing with regards to these lectures
is,
you know,
I think that we're in a time of
unparalleled possibility,
so for good and for and for evil and
that the more people that there are out
there who have their acts together,
the better the probability that we're
going to be able to manage it because
we've all got some pretty hard decisions
to make coming up real fast,
you know,
and these guys that are working on these
ai systems,
I'm hoping that the ones that are more
ethically oriented in a proper direction
will be the ones that have the upper
hand.
I'm really hoping that so yeah.
Collectively,
and what I was looking into it,
because this came up before,
that it breaks the geneva conventions if
they actually eat dead bodies,
you can't do that.
Yeah,
whatever.
It's once we have a robot war dude that
even conventions out the window.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I couldn't agree with you more and I
think I'm personally,
this is important and collectively it's
very important that,
uh,
I mean I just think it's,
I think what you wrote 12 rules to life.
We need rules.
We need rules to be able to figure out
how to navigate this thing.
That's where I think that the individual
level of analysis is the right one,
is that I'm hoping that,
you know,
that like every time someone comes up
and talks to me and says,
look,
you know,
I was in a dark place and I got my life
together and this is how it's going.
I think that tilts the scales non
trivially towards a good outcome and the
more people that that's happening to the
better.
And I don't think there's a more
effective way of doing it than to
concentrate on the individual.
Now.
I don't think there is either and it's
happening a lot,
you know,
I,
I hear it every day.
I hear it everyday.
People that find you and find a lot of
other inspirational people online and
jocko and there's so many of them.
There's so many and there's so much fuel
now for inspiration.
There's so much pretty fun that,
that inspiration could become popular.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I saw this company.
Yeah,
no kidding,
no kidding.
And encouragement.
And one of the things that's quite sad
is how little encouragement people need
and it's so touching,
you know,
because I'm constantly in a state of
being overwhelmed.
Well,
even with what happened this morning
when I went to whole foods,
you know,
because it's overwhelming to have people
come up and like they share these really
intimate pieces of their life with you
in 20 seconds.
You know,
iT's like you're an old friend,
you know,
and here's what my life was like.
It's dark,
you know,
it's dark and here's a bunch of good
things that are happening.
It's like this little blast of.
It's like the persona of the person
disappears and you get to see the real
person there for like 20 seconds.
It's like it's really,
it's overwhelming,
but every time that happens,
as far as I'm concerned,
it's a victory.
It's a victory that multiplies to as far
as I'm concerned.
So I'm hoping that,
well,
every little bit helps,
you know that.
It certainly does.
And by the way,
if you meet me and you have one of those
stories and I don't know how to react,
that's just how it is,
you know?
I go,
wow,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's good man.
Super happy.
Genuinely happy for you,
but I still don't know how to react.
That's how to react.
I don't,
I'll never will learn how to react,
how to react.
That's all you need is like,
that's great man.
I hope you keep doing it.
That's power today and it always feels
flat,
you know?
I mean like with a set is so mind
blowing and I'm saying terrific.
Yeah,
but it is terrific.
That is terrific.
It is,
it is.
Absolutely.
We just didn't have three hours.
It's gone.
Thank you sir.
Oh,
it's good to see a Joan Pearson.
You're good,
man.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Thanks very much.